GOING TO CALL THE SENATE
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MEETING TO
ORDER. OBVIOUSLY, I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SENATORS FOR A QUORUM,
BUT SENATOR ARCHULETA AND I ARE
GOING TO HOLD IT DOWN FOR A BIT.
RIGHT, SENATOR, WE ARE PREPARED,
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WHO WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF QUICKLY. SO,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CELIA
AGUIAR-CURRY, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GET US STARTED? OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE
A COMMITTEE OF OURSELVES, SO WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE A MOTION,
BUT GO AHEAD AND PRESENT. I
TRULY APPRECIATE IT. AND I WILL
ALSO BE PRESENTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. JOAN SAWYERS.
PERFECT. YOU ARE ITEMS ONE AND
TWO ON OUR LIST ANYWAY, SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE. GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE. I STARTED WORKING ON HEMP
ISSUES BECAUSE THE 2018 FARM
BILL UNLEASHED A LARGELY
UNREGULATED INDUSTRY. MY FIRST
SUCCESSFUL LEGISLATION, AB 45,
WAS THE STRICTEST HEMP LAW IN
THE COUNTRY WHEN IT WAS ENACTED
IN 2021. BUT TODAY, I'M HERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE LAW CAN BE
PROPERLY ENFORCED, INTERPRETED
AS THE HEMP MARKET GROWS, WE'RE
SEEING MORE INTOXICATING HEMP
PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD OUTSIDE
OF DISPENSARIES WITHOUT AGE
LIMITS, WHICH SHOULD BE ILLEGAL.
THIS BILL IS ANOTHER HUGE
UNDERTAKING THAT TAKES ON THREE
ISSUES EXPANDING ENFORCEMENT TO
CRACK DOWN ON ILLEGAL HEMP
PRODUCTS, CLOSING LOOPHOLES THAT
ALLOW INTOXICATING HEMP
PRODUCTS, AND MAKING SURE ALL
INTOXICANTS ARE IN THE CANNABIS
THAT ARE IN THE CANNABIS SUPPLY
CHAIN, MEANING FULL
REGISTRATION, FULL REGULATION
AND TAXATION. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS, STATE
AGENCIES AND COMMITTEES AS WE
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT THE BEST
WAY TO IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES.
WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE AMY
JENKINS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND TIFFANY DEVITT FROM THE
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
. WELCOME. THANK YOU. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME? OKAY. MADAM CHAIR,
IT'S A LITTLE QUIET, A LITTLE
QUIET. YEAH. OKAY, I'LL SPEAK
LOUDER. NOPE. YOU'RE FINE. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND THANK YOU, ESTEEMED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IT'S NICE TO
SEE YOU. AMY JENKINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. PROUD SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. AB 2223 IS ESSENTIAL
FOR REINFORCING CALIFORNIA'S
STRINGENT CANNABIS REGULATIONS
AGAINST THE RISING TIDE OF
UNREGULATED, HIGH POTENCY,
INTOXICATING HEMP PRODUCTS.
THESE PRODUCTS ARE INCREASINGLY
FOUND IN GAS STATIONS AND RETAIL
OUTLETS, AVERTING REGULATION,
TAXATION AND CRUCIAL SAFETY
TESTING. AB 2223 ADDRESSES THESE
PRESSING CONCERNS IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS. THE BILL
STRENGTHENS ENFORCEMENT MEASURES
AGAINST THE SALE OF THESE
PRODUCTS OUTSIDE LICENSED
DISPENSARIES. IT PREVENTS THE
MISUSE OF THE 2018 FARM BILL.
DEFINITION OF HEMP BY
ESTABLISHING EXPLICIT PER
SERVING AND PER PACKAGED THC
THRESHOLDS. IT PROHIBITS THE
INCLUSION OF SYNTHETIC
CANNABINOIDS IN HEMP AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS, WHICH OFTEN
CARRY SEVERE HEALTH RISKS,
INCLUDING COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT
AND ACUTE TAXATION. BY
RESTRICTING THE SALE OF THESE
PRODUCTS OUTSIDE THE REGULATED
FRAMEWORK THAT IS CANNABIS, AB
2223 PROTECTS MINORS FROM
EXPOSURE TO POTENT INTOXICANT
INTOXICANTS EASILY ACCESSIBLE
ONLINE AND WITHOUT AGE
VERIFICATION. AB 2223 ALIGNS
WITH CALIFORNIA'S VISION FOR A
WELL-REGULATED, EQUITABLE
CANNABIS MARKET. IT UPHOLDS THE
PRINCIPLES OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE AND WORKER PROTECTIONS,
AND PREVENTS THE UNDERMINING OF
OUR LEGAL CANNABIS MARKETS.
PROGRESSIVE GOALS IN CLOSING, AS
A PROUD SPONSOR, KSIA IS WELL
AWARE OF THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENTS, SUCH AS CLAIMS THAT
2.5 OR 5 MILLIGRAM DOSES DO NOT
CAUSE IMPAIRMENT. THE CBD
NEUTRALIZES THC INTOXICATING
EFFECTS. WE ARE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. WE WOULD ARGUE
THAT ALL OF THESE ARGUMENTS ARE
MISLEADING AND HOPE THAT YOU
WILL ADDRESS QUESTIONS TO US. IN
CLOSING, THIS IS A VITAL BILL TO
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS AND PROTECTING
CONSUMERS. WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRWOMAN ASHBY. ESTEEMED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
TIFFANY DEVITT. AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NOTED, I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE, WHICH IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CANNABIS
WORKERS AND CANNABIS EMPLOYERS.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 2223 CENTRAL TO
THIS LEGISLATION IS A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE, WHICH IS
THAT MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS BELONG IN THE REGULATED
MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS MARKETPLACE, REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE THC IS SOURCED
FROM CANNABIS OR HEMP. HERE'S
WHY HEMP PRODUCTS WITH ANY THC
ARE VULNERABLE TO MISUSE, ABUSE
AND DIVERSION. THE REGULATED
CANNABIS MARKET HAS NUMEROUS
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS, PATIENTS AND
THE BROADER COMMUNITY. THE HEMP
MARKET, AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOTED, IS A WILD WEST
CHARACTERIZED BY FREQUENTLY
ADULTERATED, MISLABELED, AND
HIGHLY IMPAIRING PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE TRIGGERED AN INCREASE IN
YOUTH HOSPITALIZATIONS. FULL
SPECTRUM MEDICINAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS WITH HIGH QUANTITIES OF
CBD HAVE BEEN A CORNERSTONE OF
THE REGULATED CANNABIS MARKET.
FROM DAY ONE, OUR OWN COMPANY
HAS AT LEAST 50 OR SO OF SUCH
PRODUCTS. I HAVE GREAT SYMPATHY
FOR PATIENTS WHO TODAY ARE USING
HEMP BECAUSE MEDICAL CANNABIS IS
EXPENSIVE. AB 2223 ADDRESSES
THIS TO A DEGREE BY ALLOWING
LICENSED CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
TO USE LOWER COST CBD INPUTS,
BUT PLEASE UNDERSTAND IN CLOSING
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THC
HEMP PRODUCTS ARE NOT MEDICAL
BRANDS WITH NAMES LIKE KNOCKED
OUT, UP. THAT'S THE BRAND EXCUSE
THE LANGUAGE SOURCE IN EL CHAPO,
EXTRACTS ARE NOT SELLING MEDICAL
PRODUCTS. THEY'RE SELLING HYPER
IMPAIRING NATURAL AND SYNTHETIC
CANNABIS THAT IS UNREGULATED,
UNTAXED AND UNTESTED. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING IT. THANKS. GREAT.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DO ME TWO
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL?
COME ON FORWARD. TELL US YOUR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. THIS IS ME. TWO IN
FAVOR. GO AHEAD. MORNING SARA
PALERMO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, HELLO,
SENATOR ASHBY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS NIEMER
WITHERS. I'M WITH A LOCAL
NONPROFIT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
CALLED YOUTH FORWARD, WE ARE A
SUPPORT, IF AMENDED, WE SEND IN
A LETTER TO YOUR STAFF WITH,
AMENDMENT TO THE LANGUAGE FOR
STRONGER PROTECTIONS FOR YOUTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
GEORGE MILLER, ON BEHALF OF
WEEDMAPS AND SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SAM RODRIGUEZ, ON BEHALF OF GOOD
FARMERS, GREAT NEIGHBORS, BASED
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY, WE
APPRECIATE THE MAJORITY'S
LEADERS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
REGARD. AS A FORMER MAYOR AND
ALSO FORMER, WE'RE GREAT IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2223. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SARAH DUQUETTE, ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL, RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JULIANA, ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ALICIA
PRE-GPS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO KIVA CONFECTIONS IN
SUPPORT. THANKS SEAN BACON WITH
THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. PAM
LOPEZ, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
NORML IN SUPPORT. KRISTIN
HEIDELBACH HERE ON BEHALF OF
UFCW WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
PROUD CO-SPONSORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALEX LU█N
ON BEHALF OF RESOURCES LEGACY
FUND WITH US MORE SUPPORTIVE
AMEND POSITION. WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRIE'S
EFFORTS TO TIGHTEN THE
REGULATIONS ON INTOXICATING HEMP
PRODUCTS. OUR LETTER EXPLAINS
WHY WE BELIEVE THE BILL SHOULD
BE IMPROVED TO PROTECT OUR YOUTH
, PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND TALK IT JUST ME
TWO TESTIMONY. SO REFER YOU TO
THE LETTER, SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY, IN OPPOSITION THAT IS A
LEAD WITNESS. OKAY. COME ON
FORWARD AND THEN. YEP COME ON UP
. ALL RIGHT. YOU WILL EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE US HEMP ROUNDTABLE, WHO
WORKED VERY, VERY CLOSELY WITH
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY FOR THREE
YEARS TO GET AB 45 ADOPTED.
WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. BUT I WILL SAY
THAT IF YOU COUNT BY WORDS, WE
SUPPORT 99% OF THIS BILL, THE
ONE PIECE THAT IS TROUBLING FOR
US IS THE AMOUNT OF MILLIGRAMS
OF THC THAT WOULD BE ALLOWED IN
IN A PRODUCT. I THINK THE
ANALYSIS HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD RELATIVE TO THE GOLDILOCKS
QUESTION OF WHAT'S TOO HIGH,
WHAT'S TOO LOW, AND WHAT'S JUST
RIGHT. AND WE DON'T KNOW. WE
KNOW, BUT WE HAVEN'T DECIDED
AMONGST OURSELVES WHAT'S JUST
RIGHT TO ENSURE THAT WE ACHIEVE
THE OBJECTIVE THAT THE MAJORITY
LEADER IS, IS PURSUING, WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME NOT PUTTING THE
COMPLIANT LEGAL HEMP CBD
INDUSTRY OUT OF BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
SUBSTANTIAL BUSINESS, AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN SOME ECONOMIC
ANALYZES UP UP TO $3.9 BILLION
INDUSTRY JUST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE GOOD
PEOPLE WHO ARE MANUFACTURING
THERAPEUTICALLY BENEFICIAL
PRODUCTS, NOT IN TOXIC PRODUCTS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO HELP
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. AND WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT. LET'S FIND THE
MILLIGRAM CAP THAT WORKS TO ALSO
FIND A NUMBER OF SERVINGS PER
PACKAGE THAT WORKS 5 OR 4 IN A
PACKAGE IS REALLY SMALL. WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TINCTURES,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FOUR
SERVINGS IN A BOTTLE. ABOUT THAT
BIG YOU'RE NOT GOING TO FIND
THAT ANYWHERE IN THE MARKET. AND
EVEN IF IT'S FOUR GUMMIES,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FIND THAT EITHER, BECAUSE IT'S
ECONOMICALLY NOT FEASIBLE FOR A
COMPANY TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF A
PRODUCT THAT ONLY HAS FOUR
SERVINGS, WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
FIND A SOLUTION WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE, WITH THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND OTHERS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MARK SMITH,
ON BEHALF OF ORIGINS COUNCIL, WE
REPRESENT 800 BUSINESSES IN THE
CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN. THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE SMALL
HOMESTEAD CANNABIS CULTIVATORS
ON A SINGLE LICENSE, GROWING
LESS THAN 10,000FT² OF CANNABIS.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT THE MEMBER'S
EFFORTS AT ENFORCEMENT TODAY,
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND
WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION, LIE WITH THE
OTHER HALF OF THE BILL, WHICH
DEALS WITH INTEGRATION. THÀNH
INTEGRATION IS THE NOTION THAT
YOU CAN TAKE PRODUCTS FROM A
HEMP PLANT, AND YOU CAN BRING
THEM INTO THE CANNABIS
MANUFACTURING PROCESS, AND YOU
CAN INCLUDE THEM THEN IN WHAT IS
A CANNABIS PRODUCT? OUR CONCERN
AS FARMERS IS THAT IT IS EASIER
AND CHEAPER TO CREATE
INTOXICATING CANNABINOIDS BY
GROWING HEMP, AND THEREFORE
REPLACE THE INTOXICANTS IN THE
CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN WITH THOSE
THAT COME FROM THE HEMP PLANT OR
ARE DERIVED FROM THE HEMP PLANT.
HEMP IS NOT GROWN AS AN
INTOXICATING PLANT. TO GROW HEMP
IN CALIFORNIA, YOU PAY A $900
FEE TO EITHER YOUR COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONER OR CDFA VERSUS THE
CANNABIS FARMERS WHO ARE
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS, IF NOT MILLIONS, TO
BECOME LEGALLY COMPLIANT IN
CALIFORNIA'S INTOXICATING
CANNABIS PRODUCT SYSTEM.
AMENDMENTS IN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS DEALT WITH
SYNTHETIC THC, INTOXICANTS FROM
HEMP. BUT WE ARE ASKING THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER TAKING
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE INCLUSION OF
NATURALLY OCCURRING THC THAT
OCCURS IN HEMP AT VERY LOW DOSES
AND CAN BE BIOACCUMULATED IN
CONCENTRATED. AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR THAT TO BE PROHIBITED FROM
BEING SOLD INTO THE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN AND BEING USED IN
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. BOTTOM LINE,
AS I FINISH HERE, THERE SHOULD
BE NO HOT HEMP IN A CANNABIS
PRODUCT, PERIOD. IT IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
CANNABIS SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
CREATED, THAT THE VOTERS HAVE
APPROVED THROUGH PROP 64. THANK
YOU. AND I'LL BE HERE TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OKAY. AND
THEN THOSE WHO ARE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
THEMSELVES WITH THE OPPOSITION
COMMENTS. GO AHEAD. ME TWO
TESTIMONY ONLY. MADAM CHAIR AND
ESTEEMED MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
JONATHAN BLACK. I'M THE CEO OF
CHEECH AND CHONG GLOBAL HOLDINGS
COMPANY. WE RECOGNIZE MUCH OF
THE VALUES IN THIS LEGISLATION.
SIR, I NEED JUST FOR YOU TO JUST
MAKE A STATEMENT OF OPPOSITION.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. OKAY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL RAMIREZ WITH DELTA
BEV. WE'RE A $52 MILLION
FACILITY OUT OF CANOGA PARK THAT
MAKES THESE DRINKS. AND WE'RE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOE
DEVINE WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS,
ON BEHALF OF CHARLOTTE'S WEB AND
THE ONE HEMP COALITION, WE HAVE
A SUPPORT, IF AMENDED POSITION
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO PRESERVE
REASONABLE ACCESS FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHRIS
MILLER, ON BEHALF OF CANNON
BOTTLE COMPANY, WE HAVE AN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AS WELL. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. TED WHITNEY. ON
BEHALF OF THE HEMP BEVERAGE
ALLIANCE, WE HAVE AN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. CARA GONZALEZ GARCIA WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE, WHO
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE ONE
MILLIGRAM CAP AND HAS A SUPPORT,
IF AMENDED, AS WHAT WE STATED IN
OUR LETTER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. MA'AM. DID YOU WANT TO
ALIGN YOUR COMMENTS WITH ANY OF
THOSE PARTICULAR FOLKS? ARE YOU.
NO. IT'S OKAY. YOU FEEL GOOD
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I
KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT ON A BILL
WHERE YOU HAVE PRESENTERS AND
OPPOSERS AND YOUR POSITION IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN THEIRS,
BUT THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US ON OUR PROCESS TO JUST HAVE
TWO SPEAKERS WHO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH, AND THEN EVERYBODY
CHIME IN. APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH. I KNOW, I KNOW, SOMETIMES
IT'S DOESN'T QUITE WORK OUT, BUT
GRATEFUL FOR EVERYONE'S HELP.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING TO BRING
THIS BACK TO THE DAIS AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR BECKER, I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT ABOUT, SYNTHETIC
CANNABINOIDS. AND THIS IS A
CONFUSING AREA, BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET CLARITY. SO I KNOW
YOU RIGHTLY TRYING TO GET RID OF
UNREGULATED, INTOXICATING HEMP
Tê DERIVATIVES. CORRECT HUM, BUT
WHAT ABOUT SYNTHESIZE PLANT
IDENTICAL NON-INTOXICATING
CANNABINOIDS, ARE THOSE OKAY?
OKAY. DO YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT?
YEAH. DO YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT
ONE? OH, SURE, EXPERTS ARE
BETTER THAN ME. SO THE WHAT?
YOU'RE. I BELIEVE YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS CANNABINOIDS
LIKE CBG, CBN, WHICH OCCUR IN
THE HEMP PLANT AND AREN'T TOXIC
BAITING. THE PROBLEM WITH WHEN
YOU SYNTHESIZE A COMPOUND LIKE
LET'S SAY CBN AND YOU CREATE IT
CHEMICALLY IT IT SOME OF THE
MOLECULES ARE GOING TO BE
IDENTICAL TO THE PLANT DERIVED
COMPOUND. BUT IN THE CHEMICAL
SYNTHESIS PROCESS YOU TEND TO
CREATE WHAT ARE CALLED UNKNOWN
ISOMERS MEANING MOLECULES THAT
ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN THE
ONE YOU INTENDED TO CREATE. BUT
THIS THAT PHENOMENON IS ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
HAVE WHEN THEY'RE MAKING
PRODUCTS. IN SYNTHESIZING A
COMPOUND, THE CORE ISSUE IS, IS
IT PURE MEANING ARE ALL THE
MOLECULES THE SAME, OR DO YOU
HAVE THIS SORT OF UNKNOWN STUFF?
AND WITH THE UNKNOWN ISOMERS,
THE SAFETY PROFILE HAS NOT BEEN
VETTED OR TESTED. SO MY OWN
POSITION IS, IN MY OWN BELIEF,
HAVING DUG INTO THE SCIENCE OF
THIS IS THAT CHEMICALLY
SYNTHESIZED COMPOUNDS ARE NOT
IDENTICAL TO NATURALLY DERIVED
COMPOUNDS AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S A NEED OR DESIRE FOR
THAT, IT HAS TO BE DONE IN A
CONTEXT WHERE THE SAFETY AND
PURITY CAN BE MEASURED AND
DOCUMENTED. WHAT IF THEY ARE
PLANT IDENTICAL COMPOUNDS? BUT
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS, WHEN
YOU'RE MANAGING AN IDENTICAL
PLANT COMPOUND, IF IT'S A
MANUFACTURED COMPOUND, YOU
PRODUCE NON-IDENTICAL COMPOUNDS.
SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
PROCESS OF CHEMICALLY
SYNTHESIZING SOMETHING LIKE CBG
OR EVEN DELTA NINE THC, YOU END
UP WHAT ARE WITH UNKNOWN
ISOMERS, WITH UNKNOWN SAFETY
ISSUES. SO SHORT VERSION
CHEMICALLY SYNTHESIZED
CANNABINOIDS, EVEN IF THE TARGET
CANNABIS IS IDENTICAL TO ONE
THAT OCCURS IN NATURAL NATURE,
IS NOT NECESSARILY SAFE BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BYPRODUCTS, UNKNOWN
BYPRODUCTS NOT NECESSARILY SAFE.
BUT IT COULD BE SAFE. COULD BE.
YES, ABSOLUTELY. AND THE POINT
IS THAT IT NEEDS TO BE TESTED. I
HAVE A I HAVE A FOLLOW UP TO
THAT TOO. THERE ARE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL TO THAT DO PROVIDE
THAT. IF IT IS DETERMINED TO BE
SAFE OR YOU WANT TO MAKE THE
CASE FOR IT TO BE SAFE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
THE DISCRETION TO REVIEW AND VET
THOSE SYNTHETICALLY DERIVED
CANNABINOIDS. OKAY, SO WHAT IS
THE PROCESS THEY SUBMIT IT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. OR
YES, THEY COULD THEY COULD
THEORETICALLY, YOU COULD SUBMIT
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT WOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO EVALUATE AND
DETERMINE SAFETY. AND IS THERE
LIKE A TIMELINE THEY HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU? THERE'S NO
SPECIFIED TIMELINE CURRENTLY IN
THE LEGISLATION, BUT THERE IS A
PROCESS IN PLACE TO ALLOW FOR
THE VETTING. HAVE THEY DONE THAT
IN THE PAST? THEY'VE THAT I
WOULD ASSUME SO, BUT I COULDN'T
VERIFY THAT AT THIS POINT, SIR.
ALL RIGHT. LET ME HEAR THE REST
OF DEBATE. I MAY HOLD OFF JUST I
WANT TO KIND OF GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF,
LIKE A LITTLE UNCLEAR. BUT THANK
YOU. OKAY. A COUPLE OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. MY CONCERN IS THE
CONSUMER AT THE OTHER END OF ALL
THIS CONTROVERSY, THE SENIORS
WHO HAVE TROUBLE WITH THEIR
BACKS, SPINES, WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE THAT ARE TURNING TO CANNABIS,
BUT REALIZING THAT IT'S A HIGH
AND IT AND IT AND IT SHOULD JUST
STABILIZE THE PAIN AND THEN TO
HEAR THAT SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS
ARE BEING SOLD AT GAS STATIONS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT AND SEE HOW
WELL HAPPENED? SO OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO KEEP IT IN IN A
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT. SO SUCH
AS DISPENSARIES, THEY ARE
SELLING PRODUCTS RIGHT NOW IN
GAS STATIONS, SMOKE SHOPS ONLINE
OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT PURE
AND THAT SHOULDN'T BE GIVEN TO
ANYONE UNTIL IT'S BEEN TESTED.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS BILL CAME
ABOUT, IS BECAUSE WE PUT IN
REALLY STRICT RULES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE FIND
LOOPHOLES. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FINDING. AND IT'S AFFECTING A
LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE, ADULTS AS
WELL. BUT IT'S AFFECTING THEM
OBVIOUSLY, IF IT'S WORKING IN A
MEDICAL WAY THAT IS HELPING
SOMEBODY, WE'RE NOT HERE TO
DESTROY BY THAT METHOD AT ALL.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE IT'S
GOT TO BE LEGAL, IT'S GOT TO BE
TESTED. AND THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL'S ABOUT. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU GUYS WANT TO
ADD? NO. I THINK THAT COVERS SO
OBVIOUSLY BY PASSING AB 2223 IT
WOULD ENHANCE THE SAFETY OF
THESE TEENAGERS OR SENIORS THAT
ARE WALKING IN TO THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS AND NOT KNOWING
THE AMOUNT OF HEMP THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH. AND THE AFTER
EFFECTS. I GUESS WHEN WE DID AB
45, WE PUT A LOT OF GUARDRAILS
IN THAT, AND OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
FOUND THE LOOPHOLES. YOU CAN GO
RIGHT NOW INTO A TOTAL WINE
PLACE AND SEE THC SOLD AT TEN
MILLIGRAMS IN A DRINK RIGHT NOW,
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
LABELING ON THAT. THAT'S
ACCURATE TELEPHONE NUMBERS, ETC.
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT THEY
DON'T FOLLOW THE RULES FROM AB
45. SO THIS IS JUST ENHANCED TO
MAKE SURE IT'S EVEN SAFER. MY
FEAR IS THAT THIS IS GETTING IN
THE HANDS OF THE WRONG PEOPLE,
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
A METHOD IN WHICH WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE OVERSIGHT WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD.
AND, MADAM CHAIR, I'LL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE HEARD
PREVIOUSLY, I WILL SPARE YOU MY
RANT ABOUT MY FRUSTRATION WITH
THIS WHOLE AREA. BUT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS, FIRST OF ALL, I'M
UNDER THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ENTERTAINING
AMENDMENTS, PERHAPS EVEN
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS. CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT THAT
WILL BE? MAYBE I MISSED THAT.
NO. YOU DIDN'T MISS IT. THERE
WAS A TA THAT CAME OUT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, I THINK, A
WEEK AGO. AND THERE'S SOME
SUGGESTIONS THAT THEY HAVE THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE INCLUDED
IN THE BILL. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ADDING, DO I
HAVE THE SPECIFIC ONES RIGHT AT
THIS MOMENT? NO, I DON'T, BUT I
WILL TELL YOU IS THAT THIS BILL
IS FAR FROM BEING DONE. IT'S A
COMPLEX ISSUE, AND WE'VE TRIED
TO VET IT OUT WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
PATIENTS, THE STATE AGENCIES AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED IN
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
IT'S GOTTEN SO OUT OF HAND IS
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HAD
A CHANCE TO SEE WHAT'S OUT ON
THE STREET AND WHAT'S HAPPENING.
I FORGOT TO BRING MY LITTLE. I
WAS CONSUMING IT ALL WEEKEND.
OH, YOU LOOK PRETTY. YOU'RE
AWAKE. THAT'S GOOD. AND I'M A
LITTLE HUNGOVER, BUT I TOO AM
CONCERNED. I'M CONCERNED FOR MY
GRANDCHILDREN, MY FRIENDS, MY
NEIGHBORS, AND THE ONE OF OUR
TEST WHEN WE TESTIFIED IN ONE OF
THE MEETINGS, ONE OF THE, PEOPLE
SAID, GUESS WHAT? MY DAUGHTER
AND SHE BROUGHT IN THE PACK OF
CIGARETS THAT SHE BOUGHT ONLINE.
THIS STUFF'S GOT TO STOP. AND
WE'RE HARMING YOUNG PEOPLE, AND
THEY THINK THAT EVERYTHING IS
FINE. IF YOU CAN BUY IT ON THE
INTERNET, OR YOU CAN GO INTO A
WINE SHOP OR WHATEVER, AND YOU
CAN GET THESE PRODUCTS. IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING FOR WAY TOO LONG.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT AN END TO IT.
AND I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
IS AGREES WITH ME THAT WE HAVE
GOT TO GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT THAT
IS THAT, THE SAME FOLKS THAT ARE
GETTING THESE PRODUCTS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE CAN BUY MARIJUANA
ON THE ILLEGAL MARKET JUST ABOUT
AS EASILY. YEAH. WHICH THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE THIS IN, IN PLACES
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO A DISPENSARY, MAKE SURE IT'S
BEEN TESTED, AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S SAFE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO SO THERE'S MANY PEOPLE THAT
USE IT FOR MEDICINAL REASONS.
AND, I HAVE GOOD FRIENDS THAT GO
TO THE, THE SHOPS AND MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE RIGHT PRODUCT AND
HOPE THAT IT'S TAKEN CARE OF. SO
WE'RE SETTING UP A REGULATORY,
STRUCTURE WHERE WE CAN HOPEFULLY
CONTROL THAT, EVEN THOUGH THE
ILLEGAL MARKET IS STILL GOING TO
BE, FREE TO OPERATE AS IT DOES
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR ENFORCEMENT. AND
THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF THE
PREGNANT ISSUE HERE, THIS BILL
PASSED AS IS, WOULD SEND IT TO A
KIND OF A PURGATORY WHERE IT
WOULD BE TOTALLY INEFFECTUAL
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
THERE'S VERY SIGNIFICANT COSTS
TO ENFORCE THESE THINGS IN THIS
BILL, AND THE MONEY ISN'T THERE
FOR IT, AND UNTIL THE MONEY IS
THERE, IT WILL SIT IN THIS
INEFFECTIVE STATE. AND GIVEN OUR
BUDGET PROBLEMS, I'M NOT SURE
THAT I SEE THE MONEY FOR
ENFORCEMENT BEING ALLOCATED FOR
THIS ANYTIME SOON. OAN, HOW CAN
YOU REACT TO THAT? I CAN REACT
TO IT. I WILL DO WHATEVER I CAN
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND TO GET
IT ENFORCED. AND I FEEL LIKE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN PRETTY
VOCAL AS WE'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH OUR STEPS AND GOING
THROUGH THE POLICY THAT THEY Tð
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT CAN BE
ENFORCED. SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH, WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE CANNABIS
CONTROL. WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL
OF THOSE GROUPS BECAUSE THEY TOO
WANT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ENFORCE THIS BETTER. WE CAN ALSO
USE IS THAT THE POLICE, THE
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS CAN
ALSO START HELPING US AS WELL,
SO, THE, THE, THE COMMITTEE DID
FLAG FOR ME AN ISSUE ABOUT THE
BILL OF GIVE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO PEACE OFFICERS. SO
WE ARE WORKING THE STATE
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
ENFORCEMENT LANGUAGE AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S MEANING
TO THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS. BUT I CAN'T WALK AWAY FROM
IT WHEN WE'RE SEEING SO MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE GETTING THE PRODUCT
ON THE STREETS. AND I HAVE
FAMILIES CALLING ME UP SAYING,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO? AND I
KNOW THEY'VE TOUCHED A LOT OF
YOU, PROBABLY TELLING YOU, YOU
GOT TO MAKE SURE WE GET THIS
THROUGH. WE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND OUR ADULTS.
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE. WELL,
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT COMES DOWN IN
THE PRIORITY SETTING OF THE
BUDGET. IF YOU HAVE THE
ATTENTION OF THE GOVERNOR, YOU
HAVE THE ATTENTION OF ONE OF
THREE PEOPLE THAT ARE ALMOST
SOLELY RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
BUDGET. BUT I'M BRINGING UP
ANOTHER ISSUE THERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY, COLLEAGUES,
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. ANYBODY ELSE? ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE? I WOULD LIKE A REAL
QUICK. YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS THESE ISSUES FOR
SIX YEARS, AND IT'S CONSTANTLY A
CHANGING MARKETPLACE. AS I
PRESENTED THE BILL TODAY, I TOLD
YOU IT WAS GOING TO BE A COMPLEX
. IT IS. IT WILL MAKE PRODUCTS
AND PRACTICES SAFER AND MAKE IT
HARDER FOR CRIMINALS TO SELL
ILLEGAL PRODUCTS. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN MY WORK IS DONE OR
OUR WORK IS DONE. I ASSURE YOU
THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
IMPLEMENT INTEGRATION IN A WAY
THAT SUPPORTS OUR LEGAL HEMP AND
CANNABIS INDUSTRIES, FURTHER
EMPOWERS OUR REGULATORS, AND TO
ATTACK ILLEGAL PRODUCTS AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH. AT
THE END OF THE DAY, MEMBERS, WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT HEMP
PRODUCTS ARE WELL REGULATED AND
SAFE FOR ALL CONSUMERS, WHETHER
THEY ARE USING THEM FOR
MEDICINAL PURPOSES OR JUST TO
RELAX. I COMMIT TO YOU THAT I
WILL UPDATE THE COMMITTEE ON
THOSE CONVERSATIONS, MOVE
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT, WE
ARE ONE MEMBER SHY OF A QUORUM,
SO WHEN WE GET ONE, WE WILL COME
BACK TO THAT ITEM. I, I SHOULD
HAVE MENTIONED THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH ME ON SB
1498 AS WELL, SENATOR NILA,
WHICH IS AN ENFORCEMENT BILL,
AND LAST WEEK WE ADDED THIS
ISSUE INTO PRINT, WHICH WOULD
ALLOW DAS COUNTY COUNCIL'S CITY
ATTORNEYS AND THE AG TO ALSO
HELP WITH ENFORCEMENT OF THESE
RULES, WHICH SHOULD HELP WITH
SOME OF THE OFFSET AND WOULD
MAKE HER HER BILL MORE RELEVANT.
AND IT IS GOES FROM HERE TO
HEALTH. SO THERE ARE SOME MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS TO HAVE
SOME DISCUSSION AROUND SOME OF
THE ISSUES I SHOULD HAVE ADDED
THAT WILL COME. WE'LL COME BACK
TO THAT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM,
AND THEN YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL
TO PRESENT. I DO, COLLEAGUES.
CORRECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MEMBERS. I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON MY BILL, CHAIR
MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN SAWYER, I PRESENT AB
1610, WHICH PROTECTS CANNABIS
CONSUMERS AND LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET BY ENHANCING CANNABIS
TESTING OVERSIGHT IN CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN HALF THE STATE'S
ESTIMATED CANNABIS SALES STILL
TAKE PLACE IN ILLEGAL MARKETS,
AND LIMITED REGULATIONS HAVE
GIVEN AWAY TO PERSISTENT
TESTING. FRAUD OF RISK TO
PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS, AND
INADEQUATE TAX COLLECTION. AB
1610 ENSURES CANNABIS CONSUMERS
HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE, RELIABLE
AND ACCURATELY LABELED PRODUCTS
THEY REQUIRE, REQUIRING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
CONTACT EXCUSE ME CONDUCT
IN-PERSON AUDITS OF EVERY LAB AT
LEAST ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS. IT
AUTHORIZES QUALITY AND ASSURANCE
COMPLIANCE REVIEWS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH PACKAGING AND
LABELING. STANDARDS INCLUDE
HEAVY METALS IN THE LIST OF
CONTAMINANTS TO BE TESTED AND
REQUIRING ANY PRODUCT RECALL BE
REPORTED TO THE CONSUMERS ONLINE
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY IS DALE GIERINGER,
DIRECTOR OF CAL NORML. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, DALE GIERINGER HERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NORML,
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR REFORM
OF MARIJUANA LAWS. AND
BASICALLY, THIS BILL IS DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE OVERSIGHT OF CANNABIS
TESTING LABS AT CANNABIS TESTING
IS LIKE A VITAL CONSUMER SAFETY
FEATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL,
REGULATORY SYSTEM, CURRENTLY,
ALL CANNABIS PRODUCTS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE TESTED BY A
LICENSED LAB TO ENSURE THEY
DON'T EXCEED, SAFE LIMITS FOR
CONTAMINANTS LIKE PESTICIDES OR
HEAVY METALS OR OR SUCH. AND
ALSO TO ASSURE THAT THEY
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE POTENCY
AND CONTENTS OF THE PRODUCTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S COME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT THERE ARE SOME
BAD APPLES OUT THERE IN THE
INDUSTRY, TESTING LABS THAT ARE
BREAKING THE RULES AND FAILING
TO REPORT HARMFUL INGREDIENTS OR
FRAUDULENTLY REPORTING THE THC
POTENCY ON THEIR SAMPLES. YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN THE ARTICLE IN THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES RECENTLY THAT
REPORTED PESTICIDE CONTAMINATION
IN IN MANY PRODUCTS TESTED FROM
CERTAIN SUSPECT MANUFACTURERS,
THERE'S OTHER STUDIES OUT THERE
HAVE FOUND SYSTEMATIC OVER,
STATEMENT OF THE THC POTENCY ON
CERTAIN PRODUCTS. THE LABEL DOES
NOT MATCH THE ACTUAL POTENCY.
SO, AB 1610 WOULD TIGHTEN
QUALITY ASSURANCE, OVERSIGHT,
TESTING OF TESTING LABORATORIES
IN THE MANNER DESCRIBED BY,
ASSEMBLY. THE ASSEMBLY LADY, IT
WOULD REQUIRE DCC TO CONDUCT
IN-PERSON AUDITS OF EVERY LAB AT
LEAST EVERY TWO YEARS, AND
AUTHORIZES QUALITY ASSURANCE,
COMPLIANCE, REVIEWS OF RETAILERS
AND MICROBUSINESSES, AS WELL AS
TESTING LABS. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THE FRAUD OCCURS AT THE BEYOND
THE TEST LAB LEVEL. SIR, WE NEED
YOU TO GIVE US YOUR FINAL
THOUGHT ON THAT. OKAY. WELL, I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE DID
AMEND THIS BILL SUBSTANTIALLY
FROM WHAT WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY BY
OMITTING A RATHER COSTLY
PROVISION THAT REQUIRED BLIND
PROFICIENCY TESTING. WE DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS, THE
PROVISION HAS BENEFITS ARE EQUAL
TO THE COSTS. AND WE'RE
THEREFORE DROPPING IT, BUT WE'RE
OPEN TO EXPLORING OTHER POSSIBLE
WAYS OF IMPROVING DETECTION OF
LAB FRAUD. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD.
YOU ARE YOU JUST HERE FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT OR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT? ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE
IN SUPPORT ME TWO TESTIMONY.
YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. YES. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AMY JENKINS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, MARCH AND
ASH AND CANNACRAFT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ALICIA PRIEGO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT SAM RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
OF GOOD FARMERS, GOOD NEIGHBORS,
BASED IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY,
IN SUPPORT GEORGE MILLER ON
BEHALF OF WEEDMAPS AND SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. IS THERE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY AGAINST THE BILL
, SEEING NO ONE? IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO JUST ME
TWO TESTIMONY OPPOSITION, THE
BILL AND OR ANYBODY LEANING.
GREAT. WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE, TO THE DAIS HERE.
MEMBERS, DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? COLLEAGUES ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN SAWYER, I ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
APPRECIATE YOU. WE DO NEED A
COUPLE MORE MEMBERS BEFORE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THE BILLS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR HELP TODAY.
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, THANKS
FOR BEING PATIENT. YOU READY?
WE'VE GOT, AT LEAST TWO BILLS
HERE FOR YOU, AND THEN YOU LET
ME KNOW WHAT ALL WE'RE GOING TO
DO. I'LL PRESENT THE OTHER ONE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO YOU WANT TO
START WITH YOUR OWN? YEAH. OKAY.
WE'LL START WITH THAT FILE ITEM
THREE, WHICH IS AB796. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
AM HERE TO PRESENT AB 796. THIS
BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED,
WOULD ESTABLISH CERTIFICATION
AND TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS. THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY WOULD PROHIBIT AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM CALLING
THEMSELVES AN ATHLETIC TRAINER
UNLESS THEY MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ARE EDUCATED AND TRAINED TO
SPECIALIZE IN THE PREVENTION,
ASSESSMENT, AND INTERVENTION OF
EMERGENCY ACUTE AND CHRONIC
ISSUES SUCH AS CONCUSSIONS, HEAT
ILLNESSES, AND SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST. THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION RECOGNIZES ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AS ALLIED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS, AND ARE
CLASSIFIED AS SUCH BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. THEY ARE ALSO ASSIGNED
A NATIONAL PROVIDER IDENTIFIER
IDENTIFIER NUMBER. JUST LIKE
EVERY OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL, INCLUDING MYSELF,
I SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AS THEY ARE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE HEALTH CARE TEAM FOR
OUR ATHLETES. IN FACT, NOT LONG
AGO WE WITNESSED THE IMPORTANCE
OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS FOR THOSE
WHO WERE WATCHING WHEN DENNY
KILLINGTON SAVED THE LIFE OF
DEMAR HAMLIN WHEN HE COLLAPSED
ON THE FIELD DURING THE NFL
GAME. ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE SO
IMPORTANT THAT IN EVERY OTHER
STATE, INCLUDING WASHINGTON DC,
THEY REQUIRE THAT THEIR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS BE EITHER LICENSED,
REGISTERED, OR HAVE
CERTIFICATION TO PRACTICE IN
THEIR STATE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF THEIR RESIDENTS. AND THEN
THERE IS CALIFORNIA VÀ THAT
REQUIRES NOTHING, NOT EVEN PROOF
THAT YOU HAVE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TO ACTUALLY CALL
YOURSELF AN ATHLETIC TRAINER. AS
A PHYSICIAN MYSELF, WHO GOES
THROUGH RIGOROUS LICENSING
PROCESS FOR THIS STATE, I KNOW
THAT REGULATING ATHLETIC
TRAINERS WILL ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, AS A PARENT OF TWO
YOUNG ATHLETES, MYSELF, I WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE PERSON CARING
FOR THEM IF THEY ARE EVER
INJURED IS ACTUALLY EDUCATED IN
THE PROPER TECHNIQUES TO
MINIMIZE INJURY AND THAT THEY
ARE NOT JUST CALLING THEMSELVES
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER, BECAUSE
THAT IS WHAT WE NOW ALLOW IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
AT LEAST 138 INDIVIDUALS BEING
PAID AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER IN
HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE UNQUALIFIED. THESE
INCLUDE CHIROPRACTORS, PEOPLE
WITH SUSPENDED CERTIFICATIONS OR
LICENSURES FROM OTHER STATES AND
STUDENT ATHLETIC TRAINERS WHO
DID NOT PASS THE NATIONAL EXAM
OR COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAM, AND
THE WORST PART OF ALL OF THIS IS
THAT THE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE NO IDEA THAT THE
ATHLETIC TRAINER, CARING FOR
THEM OR THEIR CHILD IS
UNQUALIFIED. AB 796 WILL ENSURE
THAT IF SOMEONE IS EMPLOYED AS
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED TO DO SO.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD THEIR
LICENSE RESTRICTED IN OTHER
STATES WILL NOT BE ABLE TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA AND WORK AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER. WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KELSEY
SPRINGER, WIFE OF FORMER NFL
ATHLETE KOREY STRINGER AND THE
FOUNDER OF THE KOREY STRINGER
INSTITUTE AND NICK HARVEY.
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. YEAH OKAY. THEY'LL TURN
IT ON FOR YOU. OKAY FANCY. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
ESTEEMED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN. MY NAME IS KELSEY
STRINGER, AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF
THE KOREY STRINGER INSTITUTE.
AND IT IS WITH DEEP SINCERITY
THAT I STAND HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF ATHLETE
SAFETY AND THE TRAGEDY THAT HAS
IMPACTED MY LIFE IN A MOST
PERSONAL WAY. MY LATE HUSBAND,
KOREY STRINGER, AND ALL PRO AND
ALL PRO OFFENSIVE LINEMAN WITH
THE MINNESOTA VIKINGS, PASSED
AWAY DUE TO HEAT STROKE IN THE
SUMMER OF 2001. HIS DEATH WAS
100% PREVENTABLE, AND SINCE
THEN, I HAVE EMPHATICALLY
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO ENSURING
THAT NO FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO
ENDURE THE SAME TRAGEDY.
UNFORTUNATELY, A RECENT REVIEW
CONDUCTED BY THE KOREY STRINGER
INSTITUTE SHOWED THAT CALIFORNIA
RANKED LAST AMONGST THE 50
STATES IN TERMS OF ATHLETE
SAFETY. THE LACK OF REGULATION
AND STANDARDS FOR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS WAS A MAJOR FACTOR IN
CALIFORNIA, EARNING THE
ABYSMALLY LOW SCORE OF 30.8 OUT
OF 100. THIS LOW SCORE PLACED
CALIFORNIA AGAIN LAST OUT OF ALL
50 STATES IN CREATING POLICIES
TO PROTECT ATHLETES OF ALL TYPES
FROM PROFESSIONAL TO YOUTH TO
COLLEGIATE TO RECREATIONAL. THIS
IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE AND A
SAD REMINDER OF THE WORK THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE. WE MUST
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT OUR
ATHLETES ARE PROVIDED WITH
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE, AND THAT THEIR
SAFETY IS OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO
LOSE A LOVED ONE DUE TO DUE TO
CONDITIONS THAT COULD HAVE
EASILY BEEN PREVENTED. I URGE
ALL OF US AS CITIZENS AND AS
SIMPLE HUMAN BEINGS, TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ATHLETES SAFETY IS NOT
COMPROMISED, AND THAT TRAGEDIES
LIKE THE ONE I ENDURED NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN. SO TODAY AND
AGAIN, CALIFORNIA SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO TAKE THE FIRST STEP
IN PASS AB 796 UNANIMOUSLY,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE ARE ALL ATHLETES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK, MA'AM.
ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE, FOR YOUR TIME. AND I
WANTED TO TAKE THANK DOCTOR
WEBER FOR AUTHORING THE BILL
THAT WILL START A LONG OVERDUE
PROCESS OF REGULATING THE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSION OF ATHLETIC
TRAINING. MY NAME IS NICK HARVEY
, AND I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ASSOCIATION AS
A GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
REPRESENTATIVE. I ALSO WORK FULL
TIME AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER IN
PASADENA AT CAL TECH. I AM HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB 796.
THERE ARE OVER 3000 ATHLETIC
TRAINERS WORKING IN CALIFORNIA,
AND AS WE HAVE HEARD ALREADY,
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT DOESN'T REGULATE ATHLETIC
TRAINING. AND UPDATED VERSION OF
A STATEWIDE STUDY WAS JUST
RELEASED, WHICH HAS DATA
PERTAINING TO ATHLETIC TRAINING
SERVICES PROVIDED TO HIGH SCHOOL
AND SECONDARY SCHOOL STUDENTS.
SOME OF THE KEY POINTS OF THIS
RESEARCH WAS. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND LARGEST NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS IN HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS IN THE COUNTRY. NEARLY 8
MILLION AND NEARLY HALF ARE
ENROLLED AT SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT
EMPLOY CERTIFIED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS. THIS NUMBER IS HIGHER
THAN IT WAS FIVE YEARS AGO.
ALMOST 10% OF THE HIGH SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE HIRING
UNQUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO PROVIDE
ATHLETIC TRAINING SERVICES. THIS
NUMBER IS HIGHER THAN IT WAS
FIVE YEARS AGO. THESE NEGATIVE
TRENDS SIMPLY REFLECT THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, AND ARE A PART OF THE
REASON CALIFORNIA IS RANKED LAST
. IN THE MOST RECENT 2023 HIGH
SCHOOL SPORTS SAFETY POLICY
RANKING PUT OUT BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CONNECTICUT AND
THE KOREY STRINGER INSTITUTE
INSTITUTE. SIMPLY PUT,
REGULATION OF ATHLETIC TRAINING
WILL HELP ESTABLISH, DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN SAFETY STANDARDS FOR
YOUTH SPORTS FOR COLLEGE AND
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETIC PROGRAMS
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND AB 796
LOOKS TO START THAT PROCESS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
TITLE ATHLETIC TRAINER IS
PROTECTED. IT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE PERSON CALLING
THEMSELVES OR EMPLOYED AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER, PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND OR
MEDICAL ADVICE TO THAT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT OR PARENT, IS
EDUCATED AND CERTIFIED.
FOLLOWING ALREADY ESTABLISHED
NATIONAL STANDARDS, AND THOUGH
PASSING THIS BILL WILL BE A
GREAT STEP FORWARD TO ENSURE
PUBLIC PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
, IT IS A SMALL STEP FORWARD,
BUT IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE
CATA WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ARE HELD TO THE SAME REGULATORY
STANDARD OF OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS DESERVE IT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE OTHERS IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
THEIR SUPPORT THROUGH ME TO
TESTIMONY, YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL? GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
WOULD KIDANI WITH L®NG HANSEN
KIDANI, PROUDLY REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES RAMS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHRIS REED, LICENSED PHYSICAL
THERAPIST AND CERTIFIED ATHLETIC
TRAINER. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE, THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL, AND WE ARE HAPPY TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
LINDSAY GOLDEN WITH CAPITOL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ALSO
PLEASED TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AND ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, SILVIO FERRARA. WE HAVE
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, PETE YOUNGMAN WITH THE
NATIONAL BASKETBALL ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ASSOCIATION IN FULL
SUPPORT OF 796. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, DOCTOR CHI KUGLER CATA
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY AND
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 796 DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU AS ALWAYS. HELLO,
DOCTOR. JAMIE DERULO, I AM THE
CATA PARLIAMENTARIAN AND WORK AT
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM OPPOSED TO AB
796? I WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND PROVIDE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO DOESN'T
WANT TO BE LEAD OPPOSITION BUT
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE A CONCERN?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE DÍAS
COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR? GO
AHEAD. SENATOR ARCHULETA. OKAY,
I THINK I MAY BE THE ONLY ONE ON
THE DAIS WHO HAD WHO HAS A SON
WHO PLAYED FOOTBALL FOR USC AND,
VERY PROUDLY WEARS HIS ROSE BOWL
RING. AND WITNESSING PRACTICES
AND WHAT YOU HAVE GONE, GONE
THROUGH. MADAM, MY CONDOLENCES
TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY, BUT I
WITH ALL THE YEARS MY SON WENT
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL BALL INTO
COLLEGE AND PLAYED FOR S¼, AS I
MENTIONED, AND LOOKING TO THE
TRAINERS, THE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT HE HAD WITH
THE TRAINERS, WORKING WITH
RODNEY PEETE NEXT TO HIM, OFTEN
TIMES IN THE SAME LOCKER, SIDE
BY SIDE. SO MY SON HAS HAS TOLD
ME OVER THE YEARS HOW THE
TRAINERS WERE ALWAYS THERE FOR
HIM. BUT I'M JUST SO SURPRISED
THAT ESTABLISHING A
CERTIFICATION VERSUS THE
LICENSING, WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THERE YET. AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO, FROM WHAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
YOU AND ALL THE TESTIMONY THAT
WE NEED TO START LOOKING FOR,
NOT JUST CERTIFICATION, BUT
TRULY LICENSING THESE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WILL TAKE
CARE OF THESE ATHLETES. AND
WHETHER IT'S ONE INJURY OR ONE
DEATH, IT'S JUST TOO MANY, SO
I'M SO PROUD THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS TOGETHER, BRINGING
US ALL TOGETHER TO PUT THIS BILL
ON THE TABLE FOR US. AND I THINK
IT'S WAY, WAY OVERDUE. AND SO
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN, I WILL
MAKE THE MOTION WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT. I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. DO YOU WANT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YES. WELL I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR.
HOLD ON. BEFORE YOU THANK ME,
LET ME GET A QUORUM FOR YOU SO
WE CAN GET A VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BECKER. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
LET'S CALL THE ROLL AND SEE IF
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM HERE
FOR THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. HERE ASHBY
HERE. WHEN? ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO. GIL HERE. ARCHULETA.
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER.
HERE BECKER. HERE. DODD. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. HERE. GLASER MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NILO. HERE.
NILO. HERE ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
IT'S FINE. NOW WE CAN ACTUALLY
TAKE A VOTE ON YOUR BILL. YES.
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. NOW. I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR ALSO, THE
PREVIOUS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE, BECAUSE WE'VE MET TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL. WANT TO
DEFINITELY THANK THE SPONSORS
AND ALL THOSE WHO CAME AND SPOKE
IN SUPPORT. THIS HAS BEEN A, IN
MY OPINION, SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
SIMPLE, SIMPLE BILL. RIGHT. BUT
WE HAVE DEFINITELY FACED SOME
UPHILL BATTLES, SOME UPHILL
CHALLENGES, WHICH WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THIS IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD RECEIVE
THE SAME RESPECT, BUT ALSO
SCRUTINY THAT WE DO OTHER
PROFESSIONS, YOU KNOW, WE ALWAYS
BOAST THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS. WE
SAY AS CALIFORNIA GOES, SO DOES
THE REST OF THE NATION, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IN THIS INSTANCE,
WE ARE NOT WE ARE NOT LEADING.
WE ARE ACTUALLY BEHIND. WE ARE
ACTUALLY AT THE VERY BOTTOM. I
WILL REPEAT WHAT I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING. EVERY OTHER STATE,
INCLUDING WASHINGTON, D.C, HAS
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEIR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS BE EITHER LICENSED,
REGISTERED OR HAVE CERTIFICATION
TO PRACTICE IN THEIR STATE. IT
IS SHOCKING AND EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTING AND CONCERNING
THAT THIS STATE HAS REQUIRED
NOTHING, AND THAT THE INACTION
OF THIS STATE HAS PLACED OUR
MOST VULNERABLE ATHLETES IN
HARM'S WAY. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF MANY NATIONAL
DISCUSSIONS, NEWS AND RESEARCH
ARTICLES BECAUSE WE HAVE CHOSEN
NOT TO DO THE RIGHT THING, AND
OUR YOUNG ATHLETES HAVE BEEN
PAYING THE PRICE SINCE THE
1980S, THERE HAS BEEN AN EFFORT
TO REQUIRE LICENSURE OR
REGISTRATION OF ATHLETIC TIME THOSE
EFFORTS HAVE EVERY TIME AN
ATHLETE HAS BEEN HARMED BY
SOMEONE FALSELY CLAIMING TO BE
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER, PART OF THE
BLAME GOES TO US FOR OUR FAILURE
TO ACT. BUT WE CAN CHANGE THAT
TODAY. WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB
796, PASSED TITLE PROTECTION FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IS THE FIRST
STEP TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA ATHLETES. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE FAMILIES OF CALIFORNIA ARE
BETTER OFF BECAUSE YOU'RE HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE. LET'S, YOU
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
ARCHULETA. LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED.
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. NGUYEN ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. DODD EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO. AYE NILA.
AYE. ROTH. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WILK. SO THAT'S SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL FOR
OTHER COLLEAGUES TO GET HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK
YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LIFE'S WORK. WE
APPRECIATE YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON
TO YOUR NEXT BILL? AB 2166? I
WOULD OKAY, LET'S DO THAT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING AGAIN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
2166A BILL TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY AND TRAINING WHEN
INDIVIDUAL IS ON PATH TO
RECEIVING A BARBERING OR
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT COSMETOLOGY
CURRICULUM FALLS SHORT IN
PREPARING BEAUTY PROFESSIONALS
TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS WITH
VARYING HAIR TEXTURES AND TYPES.
AN ESTIMATED 65% OF THE US
POPULATION HAVE CURLED, CURLY,
OR WAVY HAIR. YET OUR STATE
LICENSING AUTHORITIES DO NOT
REQUIRE SUBSTANTIVE TRAINING AND
COMPETENCY FOR STYLING TEXTURED
HAIR. THIS INSTITUTIONAL GAP AND
KNOWLEDGE CAN RESULT IN DAMAGE
TO THE HAIR OF CLIENTS FROM
VARYING CULTURAL AND ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS, AS WELL AS SUCH
INDIVIDUALS BEING UNABLE TO
OBTAIN APPROPRIATE SERVICES FROM
LICENSEES. THE ABSENCE OF
INCLUSIVE HAIR EDUCATION NOT
ONLY PERPETUATES NARROW BEAUTY
STANDARDS, BUT ALSO HAS
PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
PROFESSIONALS AND FOR BEAUTY
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE. FOR THESE
REASONS, AB 2166 WOULD REQUIRE
COURSES IN HAIRSTYLING,
BARBERING OR COSMETOLOGY TO
INCLUDE INSTRUCTION FOR
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PERSONS
WITH VARYING HAIR TYPES,
INCLUDING DIFFERENT TEXTURES,
THICKNESS AND CURL PATTERNS OR
WAVE PATTERNS. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE EXAMINATION
FOR LICENSURE TO INCLUDE
QUESTIONS ABOUT TEXTURED HAIR.
THERE IS A CAP OF CURRICULUM
HOURS OF 1000 HOURS, AND
CURRENTLY NONE OF THOSE HOURS
ARE DEDICATED TO TRAINING ON
TEXTURED HAIR. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY ASSOCIATION, WHICH
INCLUDES ESTEE LAUDER AND
OTHERS. WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS TIPPI SHORTER, A
CELEBRITY STYLIST, AND MYRA READ
READY FROM THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CARRYING
THIS LEGISLATION. I CAN'T
EXPRESS HOW MUCH IT MEANS TO AN
ENTIRE INDUSTRY, AS WELL AS
CLIENTS THAT ARE LOOKING TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN TO RECEIVE
SERVICES, AND THIS LEGISLATION
VERY MUCH REFLECTS ACCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES IN AN
ESTABLISHMENT THAT CAN BE
INSPECTED BY LICENSED BEAUTY
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE PROPERLY
EDUCATED AND TRAINED AND HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH THEIR
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE. BUT WE
BELIEVE ALL INDIVIDUALS SHOULD
HAVE THAT ACCESS AND BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES FROM TRAINED
INDIVIDUALS. WE DO REALIZE THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH A 1000 HOUR
CURRICULUM. SO I DO WANT TO
MENTION THAT THIS LEGISLATION
DOES COME WITH THE SUPPORT AND
HELP FROM THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS
THE TEXTURE EDUCATION COLLECTIVE
THAT IS WORKING TO HELP BRING
STATES INTO THIS LEGISLATION.
THE TEXTURE EDUCATION COLLECTIVE
DOES PROVIDE A TEXTURE MASTERY
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM IS FREE,
SO IT'S A FREE SERVICE THAT WE
WELCOME ALL SCHOOLS TO JOIN AND
SIGN UP. SO FAR, 7000 STUDENTS,
800 INSTRUCTORS IN OVER 166
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN TRAINED
THROUGH THIS FREE TEXTURE
MASTERY PROGRAM. THEY TALK, THEY
TRAIN FOR CUTTING, COLORING,
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES, STYLING.
THEY PROVIDE TWO MANNEQUIN HEADS
WITH DIFFERENT TEXTURE HAIR.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE MATERIALS,
TALKING POINTS ON HOW YOU
APPROACH CLIENTS. EVERYTHING
THAT A SCHOOL WOULD NEED TO HAVE
SUPPORT AT NO COST TO THE
SCHOOL. THIS PROGRAM IS DONE
WITHIN CURRENT STATE HOURS BY
INTERWEAVING ALL OF THESE
MATERIALS INTO THE CURRENT
CURRICULUM, AS OPPOSED TO JUST
SINGLING OUT A COUPLE DAYS OF A
PROGRAM TO OFFER TEXTURE HAIR
EDUCATION. SO WHEN WE'RE WASHING
OR COLORING OR STYLING, YOU'RE
UTILIZING BOTH MANNEQUIN HEADS
AND YOU'RE HAVING A CHANCE TO
INTERWEAVE THIS INTO YOUR
EVERYDAY, EVERY HOUR PART OF
YOUR CURRICULUM SO THAT IT
BECOMES CUSTOMARY, BECOMES MORE
NATURAL. AND THE ABILITY FOR THE
STUDENTS TO PICK UP ON THAT
INFORMATION AND TO FEEL MORE
RELAXED, TO APPROACH CLIENTS
WITH DIFFERENT TEXTURED HAIRS,
COMES TO FRUITION TO THEM BEFORE
THEY GRADUATE FROM SCHOOL. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT STUDENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY PAYING FOR A
PROGRAM TO HAVE TO COME OUT OF
SCHOOL AND REINVEST ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SEEK MORE TRAINING,
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T FULLY
TRAINED TO BEGIN WITH, THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP,
ESPECIALLY WITH THERE BEING A
GROWTH OF 8% IN THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY, WITH NEARLY 90,000
OPENINGS FOR NEW LICENSED BEAUTY
PROFESSIONALS TO ENTER INTO THE
STATES. IT. HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
WE HAVE 54% OF EMPLOYMENT BASED
ESTABLISHMENTS ARE OWNED BY
WOMEN, 64% BY MINORITIES. AND
THESE 15,000 EMPLOYMENT BASED
ESTABLISHMENTS WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIRE INDIVIDUALS,
LICENSED BEAUTY PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAD THIS
SPECIFIC TRAINING. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
LEGISLATION, AND WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN BRING THIS TYPE OF
LEADERSHIP TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING WITHIN
EXISTING HOURS IN EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME. I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE WITH
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT CAUSE, MY
NAME IS TIPPI SHORTER. I AM A
LICENSED HAIRSTYLIST. I RECEIVED
MY LICENSE 30 YEARS AGO IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO AN
EDUCATOR AND A CELEBRITY
HAIRSTYLIST, I RECEIVED MY
LICENSE. AS I MENTIONED, 30
YEARS AGO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHILE,
GRADUATING BEAUTY SCHOOL, LIKE
MANY OTHERS AFTERWARDS, I DID
HAVE TO REINVEST INTO MY
EDUCATION TO LEARN HOW TO WORK
ON WAVES, CURLS, AND COILS. AND
THE ASSUMPTION WOULD BE BECAUSE
I'VE GOT CURLS, I KNOW HOW TO DO
THEM. THAT IS NOT TRUE. AND I
DID NOT LEARN THAT IN BEAUTY
SCHOOL. WHEN INVESTING IN MY
EDUCATION AND ENROLLING IN
COSMETOLOGY SCHOOL, MY HOPES AND
JUST LIKE OTHER STUDENTS, THE
HOPES ARE THAT YOU GRADUATE
FEELING SET UP FOR SUCCESS. AND
I DO KNOW THAT THE FACILITATORS
AND EDUCATORS THERE ARE DOING
THEIR VERY BEST. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, WITHOUT TEXTURE
EDUCATION AND THE TEXT TESTING,
STYLISTS LIKE ME HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO SPEND MONEY ON JUST
BASIC EDUCATION ON HOW TO WORK
WITH THE BEAUTIFUL WAVES AND
CURLS THAT I ACTUALLY SEE ON
THIS PODIUM BEHIND ME. WITHOUT
THIS EDUCATION, THIS USUALLY
LEADS TO UNFAVORABLE
EXPERIENCES. I'M SURE MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WITH WAVES,
CURLS, AND COILS CAN SPEAK OF AN
EXPERIENCE OF GOING TO A
HAIRSTYLIST AND NOT HAVING THE
BEST SERVICE POSSIBLE, OR EVEN
BEING TURNED AWAY BECAUSE THE
STYLIST ISN'T, ADEQUATELY
TRAINED ON HOW TO WORK ON WAVES,
CURLS AND COILS AND TEXTURE IN
GENERAL, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
HAIR IS HAIR, BUT IT DOES COME
IN ALL BEAUTIFUL FABRICS AND
THAT'S STRAIGHT, WAVY, CURLY AND
COILY. AND I DO BELIEVE IN ORDER
TO BE A HAIR STYLIST, A STYLIST
MUST LEARN HOW TO WORK ON ALL
HAIR. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME, IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COME UP AND
SUPPORT? PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION? MADAM CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. PAULA
TREAT, ON BEHALF OF ESTEE
LAUDER, WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORTING.
NORLAND ASBERG REPRESENTING
L'OREAL AND SUPPORT. JENNIFER
HUTTER HERE FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
BOARD OF BARBERING, COSMETOLOGY
AND STRONG SUPPORT. SEEING NO
MORE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE ROSE, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. OKAY. PLEASE. WELL
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL AND TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD ON CROWN ACT AND THE
PROTECTION, PARTICULARLY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS, PROTECTION OF OUR
HAIR AND HAVING ACCESS TO MAKING
SURE THAT NO MATTER THE TEXTURE,
THE FABRIC, THE STYLE THAT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO PROFESSIONALS WHO
KNOW HOW TO DO IT AND DO IT
WELL, IT'S ABOUT BEAUTY, BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS AND
PROTECTING ALL CALIFORNIANS, NO
MATTER HAIR TEXTURE. SO THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO.
YOU THINK I'M GOING TO MAKE A
COMMENT ABOUT MY OWN HAIR? I
SAID DON'T DO IT. DON'T DO IT,
THIS IS A SERVICE THAT CLEARLY I
DO NOT NEED. BUT ALTHOUGH WHEN I
WAS YOUNGER, I DID HAVE WAVY AND
CURLY HAIR, BUT IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT I HAVE, IT INDICATES THAT
THIS TYPE OF HAIR REPRESENTS
ABOUT 65% OF THE POPULATION OF
THE COUNTRY. WHAT KIND OF A
MARKETPLACE IS IT THAT WOULD NOT
TRAIN, TO MEET 65% OF THE DEMAND
? YEAH, THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
AND I THINK WHAT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IS THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
AN INTEREST, OR THEY HAVE A HIGH
CLIENTELE, THEY HAVE HAD TO BEAR
THE BURDEN OF GOING AND HAVING
EXTRA CLASSES AND PAYING OUT OF
THEIR POCKET TO LEARN HOW TO
PROPERLY MANAGE THIS TYPE OF
HAIR, WHICH THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO DO, ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION DOES HAVE, CURLY,
WAVY, DIFFERENT KIND OF TEXTURED
HAIR, SO, SO THEY HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING THAT TRAINING JUST NOT
WITHIN THEIR INITIAL EDUCATION,
AND THEY'VE BEEN HAVING TO PAY
MORE OUT OF POCKET TO GET THAT
TRAINING. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE ON MEMBER
QUESTIONS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR? SENATORS ALL
RIGHT. SORRY. APPROPRIATIONS
NEEDED TO BORROW OUR QUORUM FOR
A MINUTE, BUT WE'RE BACK NOW,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES,
ONE TO DEFINITELY THANK THE
SPONSORS, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
LOOK INTO THE AUDIENCE, EVERYONE
HERE HAS DIFFERENT TEXTURE AND
HAIR, AND EVERYONE'S HAIR IS
JUST AS VALUABLE, JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS AS THE OTHER ONE
PERSON WHO SITS NEXT TO THEM.
AND I SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO A
HAIR STYLIST. AND THEY ARE
TRAINED IN HAVING TO DEAL WITH
MY HAIR, JUST LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN TRAINED IN DEALING WITH
YOUR HAIR. AND SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB 2166. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
. WAS THERE A MOTION? MOTION.
THERE WE GO. LOTS OF MOTION.
SENATOR BECKER WILL HAVE YOU
MOVE THAT BILL, AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE THE ROLL MOTION IS Dð. PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
I. ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER I.
BECKER. AYE. DODD. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO NILO. AYE.
ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. WILK I GOT
NINE ON THAT. IS THAT WHAT YOU
GOT? TWO. ALL RIGHT, 9 TO 0. BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE COMING
BACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
YOUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THAT
DISCUSSION. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SO DO YOU WANT TO
TAKE UP THIS ITEM NOW? HÌNH HERE
FOR MR. GIBSON. I I WILL DO AB
2862 ON BEHALF OF THAT IS YES.
OKAY SO, GOOD MORNING AGAIN. I
DO WANT TO START BY APOLOGIZING,
I JUST RECEIVED THIS
INFORMATION, SO I WILL DO MY
BEST WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON'S BILL, SO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2862, WHICH MADAM CHAIR?
I'M SORRY. HOLD ON JUST A
MOMENT. YES, IF I MAY, JUST
BECAUSE THIS THIS BILL HAS SOME
A LOT OF QUESTIONS. AND IF YOU
JUST GOT IT, IT REALLY THE LAST
HEARING THAT IT CAN BE HEARD IN
SO IT IS DOUBLE REFERRED TO
JUDICIARY. I, I KNOW THERE ARE
MANY QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. AND
REALLY GOD BLESS THIS
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FOR BEING WILLING
TO TAKE IT ON. BUT I YEAH, I
ASKED IF THERE WAS ANOTHER
HEARING, BUT I GUESS THIS IS THE
LAST OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IT GOES
TO JUDICIARY. OTHER I I'M NOT
SURE THAT WOULD BE. YEAH, I
WOULD RATHER DO IT. CAN YOU GIVE
ME JUST ONE MOMENT HERE. OKAY
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR
JUST A MOMENT.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WITH YOU ACTING AS
THE REPRESENTATIVE HERE FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON, AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE COMMITTEE
STAFF, THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL. AND I'M
RELUCTANT TO PUT YOU ON THE HOT
SEAT. THE BILL IS ALSO DOUBLE
REFERRED. SO THE REASON WE TOOK
A BREAK IS TO TALK TO THE
JUDICIARY STAFF. WE'RE WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF CLOCK AND WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF FIELD HERE FOR
SOME OF THESE BILLS. SO WITH
YOUR PERMISSION ON HIS BEHALF, I
THINK WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS
PULL THE BILL TODAY, PUT IT OVER
TO NEXT WEEK, BUT IT IS GOING TO
GIVE US A AS OUR PRO TEM WOULD
SAY, A CRUNCHY TIMELINE. SO WE
WANT TO JUST ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR AND THE FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING ON THE BILL TO BE IN
CONTACT WITH BOTH THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE STAFF, AS
WELL AS THE JUDICIARY STAFF
DURING THAT, CONCURRENTLY OVER
THE NEXT WEEK, SO THAT THE
ISSUES IN BOTH OF THOSE
COMMITTEES CAN BE RESOLVED. I'D
LOVE TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBER, AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL
PULL THE ITEM AS IF IT'S OKAY
WITH COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR I WILL
DEFINITELY MAKE SURE TO RELAY
THAT INFORMATION TO THE MEMBER.
I DO THINK IT IS BEST THAT HE BE
HERE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF
THIS COMMITTEE, BUT ALSO TO
PREPARE FOR JUDICIARY. SO I
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
DOING EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL DOES GET
HEARD, WHEN THE AUTHOR IS ABLE
TO BE HERE, YOU ARE VERY KIND TO
HAVE OFFERED TO HELP AND TO HELP
HIM GET THROUGH THIS. WE
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING YOUR BILLS AND
HELPING US WITH HIS. SO THAT
BEING SAID, WE WILL PULL ITEM
NINE AB 2862 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. WE WILL
ADD IT TO THE BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENDA FOR NEXT
WEEK. BUT FOR THOSE IF HE WOULD
LIKE IT ADDED BACK ON ON THAT
DATE AND IT WILL ALSO THEN BE UP
NEXT WEEK IN JUDICIARY. AND SO
FOLKS WILL WILL NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO BOTH COMMITTEES AT
THE SAME TIME MOVING FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. THEN WE WILL MOVE ON.
AND LET'S SEE. WE HAVE THE NEXT
ITEM UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY
WHO IS NOT HERE, AND AFTER HIM
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. BUT I
BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT BOTH OF
THOSE BILLS, IS THAT CORRECT?
ALL RIGHT. COME ON. FORWARD.
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT FIRST, MR. HANEY OR YOUR
OWN? I'LL STAY IN FILE ORDER. SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNES, AB 2115. GREAT SO WE'LL
START WITH 2115, THIS IS GO
AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. AB 2115 WILL TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA FROM A STATE WITH THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE METHADONE LAWS
INTO A STATE THAT LEADS IN
ACCESSIBILITY FOR METHADONE
TREATMENT. METHADONE IS PROVEN
TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH OPIOID
ADDICTION. IT HELPS THEM TO
CHANGE THEIR LIVES AND THEIR
TRANSITION TO SOBRIETY. IT WORKS
BY EASING THE DEBILITATING
SYMPTOMS OF OPIOID WITHDRAWAL
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE QUIT DRUGS
LIKE HEROIN AND FENTANYL, IT
ALSO REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
DYING FROM AN OPIOID OVERDOSE BY
MORE THAN 50. HOWEVER, FEWER
THAN 1 IN 10 PEOPLE IN THE US
WITH AN OPIOID ADDICTION ARE
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN TREATMENT,
AND THOUSANDS ARE DYING EACH
YEAR. NOW, DURING THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RELAXED MANY OF THE METHADONE
RESTRICTIONS. THESE RELAXED
RESTRICTIONS LED TO A HIGHER
RATE OF ENROLLMENT AND INCREASED
PATIENTS ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS.
SO LEARNING FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE, CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW,
CONTINUES TO HAVE SOME OF THE
OUTDATED METHADONE POLICIES,
WHICH ARE MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN
FEDERAL REGULATIONS. AND THIS
BILL, AB 2115, WILL MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA METHADONE
REGULATIONS ARE ALIGNED WITH
FEDERAL LAW. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE OUR
DOCTOR, JEFFREY HAHN, THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND DOCTOR LIZ JOHNSON,
AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE AND EMERGENCY
MEDICINE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR BEING HERE. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU ARE READY. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR ASHBY, VICE CHAIR
NGUYEN, MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2115. MY NAME
IS JEFFREY HOM, AND I'M A SENIOR
PHYSICIAN IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH, WHERE I CARE
FOR PATIENTS WITH OPIOID USE
DISORDER, ALSO KNOWN AS OPIOID
ADDICTION. AS YOU ALL KNOW,
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A PROFOUND
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS NATIONALLY
AND IN CALIFORNIA. DURING THE
FIRST FOUR HOURS OF THIS HEARING
ALONE, FIVE MORE CALIFORNIANS
WILL DIE OF AN OVERDOSE.
FORTUNATELY LIKE OTHER CHRONIC
ILLNESSES, OPIOID USE DISORDER
CAN BE EFFECTIVELY TREATED WITH
MEDICATIONS. METHADONE IS THE
MOST WELL STUDIED OF THESE AND
REDUCES THE RISK OF DYING BY 50.
DESPITE THIS, FEWER THAN 5% OF
THE NEARLY 1 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH OPIOID USE
DISORDER ARE TREATED WITH
METHADONE. WE MUST INCREASE
ACCESS IF WE ARE TO TURN THIS
CRISIS AROUND AND SAVE LIVES. AB
2115 WILL HELP DO THIS. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW FOR CLINICIANS
TO PROVIDE 72 HOURS OF METHADONE
TO PATIENTS TO TREAT THEIR ACUTE
WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS, WHILE
REFERRING THEM TO AN OPIOID
TREATMENT PROGRAM. AB 2115
SIMPLY ALIGNS CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH FEDERAL LAW, WHICH WAS
RECENTLY UPDATED TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH OPIOID USE
DISORDER. OTHER JURISDICTIONS
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS FEDERAL
LAW AND INCREASED REFERRALS TO
OPIOID TREATMENT PROGRAMS. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT METHADONE SAFETY AS A
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR, I
APPRECIATE THAT EVERY MEDICATION
MUST BE PRESCRIBED THOUGHTFULLY
FOR THE RIGHT DOSE FOR THE RIGHT
ILLNESS, IN THE RIGHT DOSE. BUT
MULTIPLE STUDIES OF 72 HOUR
METHADONE HAVE ONLY SHOWN
INCREASES IN LINKAGE TO
TREATMENT. MAKING METHADONE MORE
ACCESSIBLE WORKS AND SAVES LIVES
. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO. AS A DOCTOR, I'VE SEEN THE
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF OPIOID
USE DISORDER, AND I'VE TALKED
WITH FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES TO AN OVERDOSE. BUT
I'VE ALSO SEEN HOW WELL PEOPLE
DO WHEN PROVIDED WITH THE RIGHT
SUPPORTS. RECOVERY IS POSSIBLE,
BUT WE MUST ENSURE PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO START THIS LIFE
SAVING MEDICATION. AND SO I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT AB 2115. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. I'M GOING TO KEEP
IT PRETTY SHORT BECAUSE THAT WAS
JUST AN AMAZING TESTIMONY, BUT
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ELIZABETH
JOHNSON. I'M AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE
AND ADDICTION MEDICINE AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER. I'M ALSO A
STAFF PHYSICIAN AT A METHADONE
CLINIC RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AS AN EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN, EACH
SHIFT, I WITNESSED THE PROFOUND
IMPACT THAT THE FENTANYL AND
OPIOID EPIDEMIC HAS IN OUR
COMMUNITY, MY YEAR LONG
FELLOWSHIP, IN WHICH I STUDIED
EXCLUSIVELY ADDICTION MEDICINE,
IMPRESSED UPON ME THE CRITICAL
ROLE OF EARLY INTERVENTION OF
THIS DISEASE WITH TREATMENTS
SUCH AS METHADONE, AND I'VE SEEN
IT PERSONALLY SAVE HUNDREDS OF
LIVES. METHADONE IS SAFE.
METHADONE IS AN FDA APPROVED
MEDICATION TO TREAT OPIOID USE
DISORDER, AND HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF OVERDOSE
DEATH BY MORE THAN 50. JUST AS A
BACKGROUND, THERE ARE VERY FEW
INTERVENTIONS IN MEDICINE THAT
HAVE A 50% MORTALITY REDUCTION.
THAT'S IT'S TRULY A MIRACLE DRUG
. AS A PHYSICIAN AT A METHADONE
TREATMENT PROGRAM, I'VE SEEN
COUNTLESS INSTANCES WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S ANTIQUATED
REGULATIONS CREATE UNNECESSARY
OBSTACLES FOR PATIENTS BATTLING
OPIOID USE DISORDER, HINDERING
THEIR ACCESS TO THIS LIFE SAVING
TREATMENT. I STRONGLY ENDORSE
BILL 2115, WHICH ENHANCES
PATIENT ACCESS TO METHADONE,
BRINGING THESE STATE PRACTICES
IN LINE WITH FEDERAL SAFETY
STANDARDS AND CURRENT RESEARCH
FINDINGS. THIS LEGISLATION IS
CRUCIAL FOR IMPROVING OUTCOMES,
AND ADDRESSING THE OPIOID CRISIS
EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR WORK TO
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT. THOSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT WITH ME
TWO TESTIMONY. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KAREN LANG ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND SPONSORSHIP
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS, THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, AND THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. GREAT. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
GOOD MORNING. I'M JENNIFER ALI,
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR COMP.
THE CALIFORNIA OPIOID
MAINTENANCE PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE A CONCERNS
POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY I MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANY FORMAL
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THAT WOULD BE LEAD
TESTIMONY? GO AHEAD. ALL YOURS.
OH, TWO MINUTES. VERY MUCH, SO
THE CALIFORNIA OPIOID
MAINTENANCE PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF PATIENTS
AND PROVIDERS FOR 30 YEARS TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY,
EVIDENCE BASED, MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT FOR OPIOID
USE DISORDER. AND OUR COMP
MEMBERS OPERATE ABOUT 120
FACILITIES AND SERVE ABOUT
40,000 PATIENTS DAILY. OUR
MEMBERS STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF EXPANDING ACCESS TO
MEDICATION FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
OPIOID DISORDER, AND WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR'S STAFF
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
COMPROMISED ON THAT ARE IN THE
BILL. HOWEVER, WE HAVE ONE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT'S
REMAINING, AND THIS BILL WILL
CREATE AN UNTESTED PROGRAM AND
THAT THUS IT'S CRUCIAL TO
EVALUATE ITS SAFETY AND EFFICACY
, AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT IT
DOESN'T CREATE ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. REYES. AS SUCH, WE
REQUEST THE BILL, BE AMENDED TO
REQUIRE DATA COLLECTION
REGARDING THE NUMBER OF UNIQUE
PATIENTS RECEIVING MEDICATION IN
THE PROGRAM, NUMBER OF REPEAT
VISITS BY PATIENTS, NUMBER OF
DOSES DISPENSED TO EACH PATIENT
IN TOTAL, AND THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES ACCESSING TO
TREATMENT AND COMMUNITY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. AND WE THINK
IT'S CRITICAL TO DETERMINE HOW
THIS APPROACH, TO FACILITATE
FACILITATING ACCESS TO OPIOID
USE DISORDER TREATMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY, ACTUALLY WORKS. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT.
THANK YOU. PLEASE DO HANG OUT IN
THE FRONT THERE IN CASE SOMEBODY
DOES HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER ME TO TESTIMONY. NO. OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS AND ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF THEY HAVE QUESTIONS FOR THE
MEMBER. STAND IN AUTHOR HERE. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR ARCHULETA. OKAY.
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW, WHEN I
THINK OF THE METHADONE, I THINK
OF AN ONGOING TREATMENT WITH A
PATIENT THAT'S OVER A NUMBER OF
MONTHS AND, AND, BUT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE EMERGENCY, CAN
YOU WALK ME THROUGH A PATIENT
WHO COMES TO YOU THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY, THEN EVENTUALLY, I'M
ASSUMING WE'LL GET INTO A
PROGRAM. YEAH. SO, THROUGH A
PROGRAM THAT YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
BRIDGE PROGRAM. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TONS AT GETTING
PATIENTS, MEETING PATIENTS WHERE
THEY'RE AT. SO MEETING THEM IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND
STARTING TREATMENT FOR OPIOID
USE DISORDER LIKE SUBOXONE OR
METHADONE IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. SO WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK LIKE IS A PATIENT WOULD
COME IN TO US WITH OPIOID
WITHDRAWAL OR WANTING TO GET
HELP FOR OPIOID USE DISORDER, WE
WOULD START THEM ON METHADONE,
FOR EXAMPLE. I GIVE THEM A DOSE
THERE, WATCH THEM, MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT TOO SEDATED AND
THAT IT HAS THE DESIRED EFFECT.
AND THEN THEY WOULD BE SEEN BY
SOMEBODY CALLED A SUBSTANCE USE
NAVIGATOR, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
A SPECIALIST IN CONNECTING
PATIENTS FROM THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TO OUTPATIENT
RESOURCES. SO FROM THERE,
DEPENDING AT WHAT TIME THEY COME
IN AND IF IT'S ON A WEEKEND,
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY SCHEDULE AN APPOINTMENT
AT A METHADONE CLINIC THE NEXT
DAY. THEY WOULD ARRIVE THERE THE
NEXT DAY, GET THEIR THEIR SECOND
DOSE OF METHADONE, AND THEN GO
THROUGH THE METHADONE TREATMENT
PROGRAM FROM THERE. AND YOU
TRULY CALLED IT A MIRACLE DRUG,
IN TERMS OF, VERY FEW THINGS IN
MEDICINE REALLY HAVE A 50%
MORTALITY REDUCTION. SO THE WAY
I TRY TO KIND OF TEACH FELLOWS
AND RESIDENTS IS THAT TREATING
OPIOID USE DISORDER OR TREATING
SOMEBODY WHO HAS AN
UNINTENTIONAL OPIOID OVERDOSE IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SHOULD
NOT BE SOMETHING COOL THAT WE DO
AT FANCY ACADEMIC CENTERS. IT
REALLY SHOULD BE STANDARD OF
CARE, BECAUSE NOT OFFERING THAT
TO THEM IS LIKE NOT OFFERING
THEM ASPIRIN FOR A HEART ATTACK
OR ANTIBIOTICS FOR SEPSIS,
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES SAVE
LIVES TO THAT AMOUNT. MADAM
CHAIR, ALL RIGHT. ONE MORE,
SENATOR BECKER. YEAH. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL. I THINK THIS IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TREATMENT.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT WE'VE NOW DONE OVER SEVERAL
YEARS IN THIS BILL. WILL I THINK
, EXTEND THAT TO MAKE THIS MORE
AVAILABLE. AND SOME OF OUR TRIPS
TO, ANOTHER COUNTRY ACTUALLY
WENT AND VISITED A MOBILE CLINIC
AND SAW THE, YOU KNOW, HOW IT
WORKS THERE. AND I JUST BELIEVE
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. SO I
APPRECIATE IT. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NO OTHER COMMENTS, I JUST MAKE
ONE COMMENT. ALSO APPRECIATE THE
BILL. APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES
HERE WHO ARE DOING THE HARD WORK
EVERY DAY OUT IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO SERVE FOLKS. AND THIS BILL IS
DOUBLE REFERRED. SO IT'LL GO TO
HEALTH NEXT. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU HAVE SOME REQUESTS,
DATA COLLECTION IS A PRETTY
REASONABLE ONE. I'M SURE THE
AUTHOR WILL WORK WITH YOU, BUT I
ALSO THINK, THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF WOULD BE A GOOD GROUP FOR
YOU TO SPEAK TO IN THAT REGARD.
USUALLY THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
LOVES COLLECTING DATA, SO I
CAN'T IMAGINE THERE'D BE TOO
MANY RUFFLED FEATHERS AROUND
THAT. BUT WE WOULDN'T DO IT IN
THIS COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT, IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL,
SENATOR BECKER, DID YOU MAKE A
MOTION? I WILL MAKE A MOTION.
OKAY, SO YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR BECKER. WOULD YOU LIKE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER? THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HEANEY, I'M ALSO HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO PASS BACK SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK AS WELL. AND CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE SPONSOR AND
OTHER SUPPORTERS AS WELL ON
MAKING SURE THAT DATA COLLECTION
IS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY CAN
VET. WE OF COURSE, DON'T WANT,
YOU KNOW, EXCESSIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE GOING TO SET BACK AND
COMPLICATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SOME OF THIS IMPORTANT ACTIVITY.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE IS
AMBIGUITY FOR SOME OF THESE
PATIENTS, ULTIMATELY RESULTING
IN LESS PATIENTS HAVING ACCESS
TO METHADONE BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE EXISTING INTENSE
REQUIREMENTS, LIKE STANDING IN
LINE EVERY DAY TO RECEIVE A
SINGLE DOSE OF METHADONE. IT'S
OFTEN DISSUADING SOME OF THE
PATIENTS FROM CARE, AND THEY
HAVE TO SPEND FAR TOO MUCH OF
THEIR TIME GETTING ENROLLED AND
THEN STAYING ENROLLED THAN OTHER
ASPECTS OF THEIR RECOVERY, LIKE
FINDING A JOB IN STABLE HOUSING,
WHICH IS INTERRUPTED. SO THIS
BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
PATIENTS CAN EASILY ACCESS
TREATMENT, REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR
PROVIDERS, AND PREVENT
UNNECESSARY DEATHS. AND ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER HEANEY,
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT MOTION FROM SENATOR
BECKER. LET'S CALL THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. I. ARCHULETA
AYE. BECKER. BECKER I DODD.
EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLASER.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I NILO NILO I
ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
SEN WILK. THIS IS THE HANEY
BILL. DO YOU WANT TO CUT? I LOVE
THAT BILL. OKAY, WILK. I ALL
RIGHT, WELL, WITH SENATOR
WILCOX, ENTHUSIASTIC
PARTICIPATION. I THINK WE'RE AT
NINE ZERO. WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
FOR MR. HANEY AND COME BACK TO
IT WHEN WE HAVE A FULL AUDIENCE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE
EARNED THE RIGHT HERE TO PRESENT
YOUR OWN BILL. GO AHEAD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GRATEFUL. WELL,
MEMBERS AND MADAM CHAIR, THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR A CHANCE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2832. IT
WOULD ENABLE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO TAKE OWNERSHIP OF
CONTRACTING WITH INTERNATIONAL
ENTITIES IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES.
DUE TO THE STATE'S RESTRICTIONS
ON PAYMENT AND CONTRACTING, BOTH
DEPARTMENTS MUST RELY ON THIRD
PARTY FIDUCIARIES WHEN
CONDUCTING SOME OF THE FOLLOWING
ACTIVITIES HANDLING CONTRACTS
WITH TRADE SHOW ORGANIZERS.
PAYING VIA WIRE TRANSFER OR
CREDIT CARD, WHICH IS STANDARD
AND EXPECTED PAYMENT FOR TRADE
SHOW ORGANIZERS PAYING IN
FOREIGN CURRENCY, WHICH IS
STANDARD, AND EXPECTED PAYMENT
FOR TRADE SHOW ORGANIZERS. SOME
OF THESE RESTRICTIONS RESULT IN
ADDED FINANCIAL COSTS, AS WELL
AS THE LIMITED FLEXIBILITY AND
AUTONOMY WHEN CONDUCTING
BUSINESS WITH INTERNATIONAL
ENTITIES. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE
EXEMPTIONS TO ALLOW BOTH
DEPARTMENTS TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
AGREEMENTS FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS. THIS MUCH NEEDED CHANGE
WILL MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT TO
UTILIZE EXISTING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND TRADE PROMOTION
ACCOUNTS, AND SPECIFY GRANT
FUNDS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA EXPORTERS.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON FILE.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. GREAT. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE TO,
VOICE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION? YOU
COME UP TO THE MIC NOW. GREAT.
SEEING NO ONE COLLEAGUES. ALL
RIGHT. OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. GREAT I JUST NEED A
MOTION. MOVE BY SENATOR EGGMAN
WILL TAKE THE ROLE. MOTION IS
Dð. PASS THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. WHEN ALVARO GIL.
ALVARO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. DODD. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO NILO. AYE.
ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
WILK. AYE ALL RIGHT, THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO, BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GET A
FEW MORE MEMBERS DOWN HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU
FOR HELPING US MOVE OUR AGENDA
ALONG. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD, WE
APPRECIATE YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NGUYEN. YOU'RE UP. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING. I THINK
IT'S STILL MORNING, RIGHT? YES
ABOUT 30 MINUTES. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, DID
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU ARE LOOKING
TO SELL YOUR HOME, THERE IS A
FORMAL AGREEMENT THAT NEEDS TO
BE HAD WITH A LISTING AGENT?
HOWEVER THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO BUY A HOME.
AB 2992 REQUIRES AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE BUYER'S AGENT AND
THE BUYERS WITHOUT LEGAL
PROTECTION. BUYERS AND BROKERS
ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO POTENTIAL
DISPUTES OVER COMPENSATION,
THÀNH, LEGAL UNCERTAINTIES AND
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
ANNA BUCK, SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, ANNA BUCK, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS, REPRESENTING NEARLY
200,000 REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE PLEASED TO BE
THE SPONSORS OF AB 2992. AND I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NUMEROUS BENEFITS,
BUYER BROKER COMPENSATION
AGREEMENTS OFFER HOME BUYERS
REAL ESTATE AGENTS, AND THE
MARKET AS A WHOLE. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THESE AGREEMENTS,
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY STATUTORILY
REQUIRED IN 18 STATES, PROVIDE
CLEAR AND DEFINED ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN THE
BUYER AND THEIR AGENT. THIS
CLARITY HELPS TO ESTABLISH TRUST
AND ENSURES THAT BOTH PARTIES
ARE ON THE SAME PAGE. FROM THE
OUTSET. WHEN A BUYER SIGNS A
REPRESENTATION AGREEMENT, THEIR
AGENT HAS A FIDUCIARY DUTY AND
IS COMMITTED TO WORKING IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST, PROVIDING
DEDICATED SERVICE, EXPERT ADVICE
AND ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR CLIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
HOME. BUYING PROCESS. MOREOVER,
BUYER BROKER AGREEMENTS PROMOTE
PROFESSIONAL ISM AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY BY FORMALIZING
THIS RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BUYERS
AND THEIR AGENTS. THESE
AGREEMENTS SET CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED. THIS
PROFESSIONAL COMMITMENT ENSURES
THAT AGENTS ARE FULLY INVESTED
IN THEIR CLIENT'S SUCCESS,
LEADING TO BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
HOME BUYERS. AGENTS ARE
MOTIVATED TO LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERTISE, MARKET KNOWLEDGE, AND
NEGOTIATION SKILLS TO SECURE THE
BEST POSSIBLE DEAL FOR THEIR
CLIENTS. FURTHERMORE, BUYER
BROKER AGREEMENTS HELP TO
PROTECT THE INVESTMENT OF TIME
AND RESOURCES THAT REAL ESTATE
AGENTS DEDICATE TO THEIR CLIENTS
. THE HOME BUYING PROCESS CAN BE
LENGTHY AND COMPLEX, REQUIRING
SIGNIFICANT TIME INVESTMENT FROM
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS. WHEN
BUYERS COMMIT TO WORKING
EXCLUSIVELY WITH ONE AGENT
THROUGH A BUYER BROKER
REPRESENTATION AGREEMENT, IT
FOSTERS A COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP BUILT ON MUTUAL
RESPECT. THIS PARTNERSHIP
ENCOURAGES AGENTS TO GO THE
EXTRA MILE KNOWING THEIR HARD
WORK WILL BE REWARDED, AND
ULTIMATELY LEADS TO A MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND SATISFYING HOME
BUYING EXPERIENCE FOR THE CLIENT
AND THE AGENT FROM MARKET. FROM
A MARKET PERSPECTIVE, BUYER
BROKER AGREEMENTS CONTRIBUTE TO
A MORE STABLE AND TRANSPARENT
REAL ESTATE ENVIRONMENT. THEY
ENCOURAGE FAIR COMPETITION AMONG
REALTORS AND OTHER REAL ESTATE
AGENTS, AS BUYERS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SELECT PROFESSIONALS
BASED ON MERIT, EXPERTISE AND
THE QUALITY OF SERVICES
PROVIDED. THIS COMPETITIVE
DYNAMIC DRIVES EXCELLENCE WITHIN
OUR INDUSTRY, RAISING THE
STANDARD OF CARE AND SERVICE
THAT ALL BUYERS EXPECT TO
RECEIVE. IN CONCLUSION, BUYER
BROKER REPRESENTATION AGREEMENTS
ARE A VITAL TOOL IN ENHANCING
THE HOME BUYING EXPERIENCE. THEY
FOSTER TRUST, PROFESSIONALISM,
ACCOUNTABILITY, REDUCE CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST, PROTECT THE
INVESTMENT OF AGENTS AND
CONTRIBUTE TO A MORE COMPETITIVE
AND TRANSPARENT REAL ESTATE
MARKET. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY. ALL RIGHT. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE IN A METOO POSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
AND SUPPORT THE BILL WITH YOUR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION?
HI THERE. MCKINLEY THOMPSON
MORLEY, ON BEHALF OF ZILLOW IN
SUPPORT. GREAT. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? ALL
RIGHT THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DÍAS COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
. ALL RIGHT. I DO HAVE ONE
COMMENT, AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR WILK,
AS YOU SAW, I'M SURE, IN THE
COMMENTS FROM THIS COMMITTEE
STAFF, WE DO HAVE TWO CONCERNS.
ONE IS THE PLACEMENT, WHICH
SECTION OF THE CODE THIS SHOULD
BE PLACED IN, WHETHER IT'S THE
CIVIL CODE OR WHERE YOU'RE
CURRENTLY PROPOSING IT TO BE
PLACED. AND THEN THE SECOND
PIECE IS NAVIGATING THE CURRENT
AND PENDING LAWSUIT. HOWEVER, I
BELIEVE BOTH OF THESE ISSUES ARE
BETTER RESOLVED OR MORE
APPROPRIATELY RESOLVED IN SENATE
JUDICIARY, WHICH IS WHERE YOU
ARE DOUBLE REFERRED TO NEXT. I
WILL SEE YOU THERE SHOULD YOU
SUCCESSFULLY LEAVE THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT I DO THINK THAT
YOU SHOULD BE PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THOSE TWO ISSUES AS YOU
HEAD TO THAT COMMITTEE. SHOULD
THIS GROUP BODY DECIDE TO SEND
YOU ON OKAY, ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, FOR BRINGING THAT UP. AND
YES, WE'RE IN CONVERSATION WITH
THAT COMMITTEE AS WELL, THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION,
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GREAT. YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR WILK WILL TAKE THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ASHBY Ã
ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO
GIL ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLAZER.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I NILO I NILO
I ROTH SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK I
WILK I. ALL RIGHT, 9 TO 0, BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL A FEW
MEMBERS. STILL TO COME. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HAVE A
GREAT DAY. AND WE ARE. WE WILL.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
MIGHT BE HERE FOR ITEM 12, THE
ITEM WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
THAT WAS AB29 80 BY LOW THAT
THAT ITEM HAS BEEN PULLED. SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR GREAT. THIS
IS ITEM TWO. AND THREE. NØ FIVE
AND SIX. SORRY, FIVE AND SIX.
ASHBY I ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO GIL ALVARADO GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER I
BECKER I DODD EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLAZER MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO
I NEAL I ROTH SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
WILK WILK I. ALL RIGHT, THAT'S
NINE ZERO. ON CONSENT. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON. CALL FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS. AND THEN WE HAVE ITEM.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR OUR LAST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WE HAVE ITEMS
ONE AND TWO THAT STILL HAVE NOT
BEEN VOTED ON, AND WE CAN TAKE
THOSE UP. LET'S GO TO ITEM ONE,
WHICH IS ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUILAR
CURRY, HER CANNABIS INDUSTRIAL
HEMP BILL. IS THERE A MOTION? I
HAVE A MOTION. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR ARCHULETA MOVES THE
BILL. LET'S TAKE THAT UP. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. HI, ASHBY. I
NGUYEN ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO.
GIL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
BECKER. DODD EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLAZER. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO
NILO I ROTH. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
WILK. NOT VOTING. OKAY, THAT
ITEM HAS SIX VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. LET'S TAKE UP ITEM
TWO. THIS IS MR. JONES SAWYER'S
BILL. WE ALSO NEED A MOTION HERE
. I'LL MOVE IT. MOVED BY SENATOR
BECKER, THIS IS AB 1610, FILE
ITEM TWO. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY Ã ASHBY I.
WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL
ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLAZER.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I NILO I NEAL
I ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK
WILK I ALL RIGHT, THAT'S NINE O
ON ITEM TWO. WILL ALSO LEAVE
THAT ONE ON CALL. THAT'S IT FOR
OUR ITEMS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
HEARD OTHER THAN ITEM 12, WHERE
WE WAIT FOR MR. ALVAREZ. I THINK
WE MIGHT HAVE A FEW MEMBERS WHO
WEREN'T HERE FOR FILE ITEM
THREE, WHICH WAS ASSEMBLYWOMAN
WEBBER'S ATHLETIC TRAINERS. BILL
AB 796. MAYBE WE COULD OPEN THE
ROLL ON THAT AND ADD A COUPLE
MORE FOLKS IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
JUMP IN. THIS IS ITEM THREE AB
796. OKAY. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE NGUYEN
NGUYEN I DODD GLAZER. ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK WILK I
OKAY, THAT ONE SITS AT NINE NOW.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL AND GO TO
FILE ITEM FOUR WHICH IS WEBER
AGAIN AB 2166 BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. CURRENTLY NINE
VOTES ON RECORD OKAY. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING. AYE. DODD
GLASER. ROTH. WILK WILK. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE'S AT TEN.
VESTED CONSENT AT HANEY. BILL, I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL FOLKS OR AWARD. NO.
HE DID. HE CAME IN LATE. ALL
RIGHT, SO WE WILL WAIT FOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. I'M
SURE. OKAY.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE ON YOUR ITEM HERE.
AB 2996. WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THIS IS OUR LAST ITEM ON FILE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
GETTING OVER HERE. THANKS TO THE
STAFF ALSO FOR WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND THE ANALYSIS, JUST A
VERY BRIEFLY, MY INTEREST IN
THIS STARTED AS A RESULT OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS. THERE'S STILL,
UNFORTUNATELY, OTHER HURDLES
SUCH AS INSURANCE HURDLES THAT
MAKE IT DIFFICULT IN OBTAINING
PROPERTY INSURANCE IN ORDER TO
BUILD HOUSING. AND SO THERE WAS
A SPECIFIC PROJECT IN MY
COMMUNITY, 5000 UNITS OF FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER OPPORTUNITIES IN
CONDOMINIUMS THAT ACTUALLY, TO
THIS DAY, HAS NOT BROKEN GROUND.
AS A RESULT OF THE INSURANCE
SITUATION. SO, THIS BILL IS
BEFORE YOU, WHICH ATTEMPTS TO,
ESSENTIALLY WOULD, UTILIZE THE
BOND MARKET THROUGH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK, THE EYE
BANK, TO EXTEND PAYMENTS THAT
ARE DUE AS A RESULT OF
POTENTIALLY THE, AN ASSESSMENT,
AS A RESULT OF THE PARTICIPATING
IN THE FAIR PLAN, WHICH WE KNOW
IS ALREADY OVERSUBSCRIBED. SO
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE MARKET TO UTILIZE A NEW
TOOL TO HOPEFULLY INCENTIVIZE
FOLKS FROM STAYING IN THE
MARKET, PERHAPS RETURNING TO THE
MARKET A LITTLE SMALL PART OF
THE OVERALL, INSURANCE CRISIS
THAT YOU ALL ARE AWARE ARE WELL
AWARE OF. SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EYE VOTE. AND MR.
DONMOYER WILL BE MY ONLY WITNESS
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GO RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATORS DAN DONMOYER,
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU, MR.
ALVAREZ, FOR THAT PRESENTATION.
I'LL JUST AMPLIFY A FEW COMMENTS
HERE, AS MR. ALVAREZ SAID, HIS
DISTRICT HAS A GREAT PROJECT
CALLED OTAY MESA. WE HAVE ABOUT
4000 CONDOMINIUMS, WHICH IS THE
MOST AFFORDABLE AND ATTAINABLE
FOR SALE HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ABOUT HALF THE MEDIAN
PRICE, ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. THE MEDIAN PRICE FOR A
HOME IN CALIFORNIA NOW IS
$904,000. SO THIS IS A HOME
PRODUCT FOR $500,000. SO THE
QUESTION IS KIND OF WHY IS CBI
GETTING INTO THE INSURANCE
BUSINESS? AS YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
BUY A HOME, UNLESS YOU PAY CASH,
IT'S PRINCIPAL INTEREST TAX AND
INSURANCE. AND WHEN INSURANCE IS
NOT AVAILABLE, ALL YOU REALLY
CAN'T SELL HOMES, YOU CAN'T
RESELL OLD HOMES. BUT YOU ALSO
CAN'T SELL NEW HOMES. WE HAVE A
BROAD BASED SUPPORT FROM THIS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT, IT'S NOT
JUST HOME BUILDERS, BUT THIS
ALSO THIS BILL WILL EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF THE FAIR PLAN TO
TAKE ON MORE RISK, WHICH WE'RE
ASKING FOR AS THE COMMISSIONER
WORKS OUT HIS SUSTAINABLE
STRATEGY. AND SO THIS IS A STOP
GAP MEASURE TO MAKE SURE THE
FAIR PLAN IS MORE SOLVENT OR AT
LEAST HAS GREATER CLAIMS PAYING
CAPACITY, THIS IS A TRIED AND
TESTED APPROACH. THE EYE BANK
THAT'S BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW MR.
VARGAS NOW, CONGRESSMAN VARGAS,
IN 2002, AN IDENTICAL CONCEPT
WAS FLOATED, AND THAT CONCEPT
CREATED A BACKSTOP AND A FUNDING
MECHANISM WHEN THE WORKERS COMP
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA COLLAPSED
AFTER IT WAS DEREGULATED, OVER A
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLARS IN
BONDS WERE FLOATED SUCCESSFULLY,
AND EVERY CLAIM WAS PAID. SO OUR
GOAL IN DOING THIS IS TO EXPAND
THE FAIR PLAN. AND THE GREAT
PART ABOUT THIS, THIS IS AN
OPTIONAL TOOL. THE FAIR PLAN CAN
USE IT, AND IT WOULD USE IT IF
THERE'S A MAJOR FIRE. AND THE
FAIR PLAN WAS TO PROVE ITSELF
UNABLE TO PAY CLAIMS UNDER ITS
CURRENT CLAIMS PAYING CAPACITY.
SO THE ONLY LAST THING I'LL SAY
IS THERE ARE CURRENTLY TEN FIRES
BURNING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE SIT HERE TODAY,
SO WE HOPE THIS TOOL IS NEVER
USED, BUT THERE'S A 50% CHANCE
IT WILL BE USED THIS YEAR. LET
ME CONCLUDE BY JUST SAYING WE DO
HAVE A BROAD BASED COALITION OF
26 GROUPS. THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE, NO ONE'S OPPOSED TO
IT AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
ME Tð TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND SENATORS
PETER ANSEL, CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
INDIRA MCDONALD HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE
BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS,
CARLOS GUTIERREZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE, CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE,
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE, WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE DICE.
COLLEAGUES, YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU, CAN YOU, THE WITNESS
OR THE AUTHOR TALK ABOUT. SO THE
I BANK WAS IS ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE, RIGHT? SO THIS
HAS TAKEN A STEP AWAY FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND HOW DO HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT? I WOULD SAY THAT IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY. SO ALL THE
COSTS OF ADMINISTERING THIS
PROGRAM WOULD STILL BE ON THE
INSURANCE MARKET. IT WOULD NOT
BE A COST. THERE WOULD BE NO
ASSOCIATED COSTS THAT WOULD BE
DRAWN DOWN FROM THE EXISTING, I
BANK STRUCTURE. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT IT'S AN ADDITIONAL TOOL.
IT'S NOT TAKING AWAY FROM ANY OF
THE WORK THEY CURRENTLY DO. IT
WOULD ALLOW FOR, I BANK TO BE
THE CONDUIT, IF YOU WILL, OF
ISSUANCE OF, OF THESE BONDS,
WHICH WOULD BE THE WAY IN WHICH
YOU COULD AMORTIZE ESSENTIALLY
THE COST OF A POTENTIAL WILDFIRE
OR OTHER MAJOR DISASTER THAT
WOULD THEN AND THEN THE FAIR
PLAN IS, IS ON THE HOOK FOR THE
BONDS? NO, THE, THE, THEY ARE
THE THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
ISSUE THE BONDS, BUT THE ALL OF
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY AND ALL OF
THE, POTENTIAL BILL COSTS AND
RISKS, THANK YOU, WOULD BE ON
THE, THE PRIVATE INSURANCE
MARKET. AND IT'S WRITTEN THAT
WAY SPECIFICALLY. AND THERE WERE
, MORE, I THINK, TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS MADE IN ORDER TO MAKE
THAT ABSOLUTELY, 100% CLEAR.
OKAY. JUST ANOTHER WAY FOR THE
FAIR PLAN TO BE ABLE TO FUND,
PAYOUTS. CORRECT. INSTEAD OF ALL
AT ONCE. IF YOU GO FOR A BOND,
YOU CAN PAY IT OVER TIME. AND IT
BECAME HOPEFULLY BECOMES AN
ATTRACTIVE, TOOL FOR THE MARKET
TO, NOT LEAVE CALIFORNIA. AND DO
WE? AND WE HAVE FAITH THAT WE'VE
TESTED THAT, THAT THERE WILL BE
A BOND MARKET FOR, FOR
INSURANCE. I THINK I'LL DEFER TO
MR. DUNMEYER AND THE HISTORY OF,
AS HE REFERRED TO IN HIS
TESTIMONY. YEAH. YOU'RE SPOT ON.
THE KEY QUESTIONS THERE. SO
AGAIN, THIS WAS TESTED AS AN
INSURANCE MECHANISM IN 2002
THROUGH 2010. SO YOU'RE CORRECT,
SENATOR. IT'S HISTORICALLY
VIEWED AS AN INFRASTRUCTURE
BANK. BUT WE AS A STATE HAVE
USED IT EFFECTIVELY. AS THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SAID CORRECTLY,
100% OF THE COST IS BORNE BY
INSURERS. WHY THIS IS A BENEFIT
TO THEM. AGAIN, AMPLIFYING THE
COMMENT WITHIN 30 DAYS UPON LACK
OF FUNDS IN THE FAIR PLAN, THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY HAS TO WRITE
THE BILLION DOLLAR CHECKS. THIS
ALLOWS FOR THE EYE BANK TO
PURSUE THE BOND MARKET, AND IN
FLOATING, IT'S LIKE INSTEAD OF
PAYING A MORTGAGE IN ONE DAY,
YOU PAY IT IN TEN YEARS. SO IT
BASICALLY REDUCES HOW MUCH IS
PAID QUICKLY, WHICH KEEPS THE
MARKET MORE STABLE. SO YOUR LAST
QUESTION ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY,
IT HAS WORKED TO THE TUNE OF A
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLARS IN
THE PAST. THE MARKET IS THE
MARKET, BUT RIGHT NOW THE EYE
BANK IS IN VERY STRONG POSITION.
IT'S ONLY CAPITALIZED 2 BILLION
AND HAS CAPACITY OF 15 BILLION.
SO WE ARE NOT OVER CAPITALIZED
AT THIS POINT IN THE EYE BANK.
AGAIN, WALL STREET IS WALL
STREET, BUT RIGHT NOW MONEY HAS
PROVEN TO BE AVAILABLE FOR BONDS
LIKE THIS. AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO PLACE
IT IF FOR SOME REASON THEY
DON'T, THEN THEN THERE'S NOT THE
TOOL, BUT THERE'S NO RISK TO THE
FAIR PLAY BECAUSE THE INSURERS
BEAR THE RISK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY. FIRST, SENATOR,
SENATOR EGGMAN, DID YOU GET YOUR
ANSWER SUFFICIENTLY? OKAY. AND
THEN WE HAVE SENATOR NILO, AND
THEN SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, MR. DUNMORE,
ARE YOU INDICATED THAT THIS TOOL
IF NEEDED? BUT WOULDN'T BE USED
IF NOT NEEDED? WHICH IMPLIES
THAT WE HOPE WE DON'T NEED IT,
TELL US WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS IS
NOT PASSED AND THE CIRCUMSTANCE
COMES ABOUT WHERE IT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE NEEDED? TALK US
THROUGH WHAT HAPPENS. WELL,
SENATOR, THERE'S A TECHNICAL
TERM WE USE IN THE INSURANCE
WORLD, HAVING WORKED THERE FOR
25 YEARS, IT'S CALLED THE DEATH
SPIRAL. SO THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
SOUNDS FUN I KNOW. SO YEAH, WE
HAVE THAT AS WELL. IF IN FACT
THE FAIR PLAN WERE TO RUN OUT OF
FUNDS WITHOUT THIS BACKSTOP
MECHANISM, THEN THE FAIR PLAN
ASSESSES THE MEMBER COMPANIES
WHICH IN ENGLISH MEANS STATE,
FARM, FARMERS, ALL STATE, ETC.
IT IMMEDIATELY HAVE TO PAY
WITHIN 30 DAYS. NOW SMALLER
COMPANIES ARE THE ONES YOU NEED
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT AS SMALLER
CARRIERS. SO A SMALL CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANY LIKE PADDOCKS
ASSOCIATION COULD GO INSOLVENT.
WE SAW THAT AFTER THE PARADISE
FIRE. SO WITHOUT THIS MECHANISM,
THE ABILITY FOR INSURERS TO PAY
OVER TIME, THEY HAVE TO WRITE A
BIG CHECK OUT OF SURPLUS TODAY
THAT JEOPARDIZES THE CLAIMS
THEY'LL HAVE IN THAT FIRE, BUT
ALSO JEOPARDIZES THEIR ABILITY
TO PAY THE FAIR PLAN BY USING
THIS INSTRUMENT, YOU EFFECTIVELY
LOAN OVER 1020 YEARS. THIS
MONEY, AND IT MEANS COMPANIES
HAVE TO PAY A SMALLER AMOUNT
OVER TIME, WHICH MEANS THEY
DON'T HAVE TO NON-RENEW AS MANY
POLICIES. THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO
BANKRUPT. SO IT IS, IN A SENSE A
BRIDGE TO KEEP THE PROGRAM
WORKING WELL. BUT WITHOUT THIS
MECHANISM, THERE IS GOING TO BE
AN IMMEDIATE PAYMENT IN THE
SMALLER CARRIERS WILL GO
BANKRUPT. THE LARGER COMPANIES
STILL, IN ORDER TO KEEP THEIR
SURPLUS PROPER TO THEIR RISK,
WILL HAVE TO START NON-RENEW
MORE COMPANIES. EXCUSE ME
NON-RENEWED MORE INSUREDS. AND
THAT'S GOING TO RESULT IN WHAT
WHAT I JUST DESCRIBED AS A DEATH
SPIRAL. SO THIS MITIGATES IT. IT
DOESN'T STOP IT, BUT IT DOES
MITIGATE THAT FROM OCCURRING.
DEATH SPIRAL SOUNDS LOVELY I
KNOW, BUT THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
YES, I GUESS I'VE GOT SOME
COMMENTS AND THINKING THAT YOU
HAVE BECOME IBANK IS A PILLAR TO
THE INDUSTRY, THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY, BECAUSE THEN THE
OTHER, OF COURSE, WOULD BE THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY. AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN CALIFORNIA
IS BUILD HOUSING AND SO ON. AND
ONE BEGETS THE OTHER WITHOUT THE
HOUSING, THEN WE'RE IN TROUBLE
WITHOUT THE INSURANCE TO PROVIDE
FOR THAT HOUSING AND
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE,
AND THEN OF COURSE, BACKING OF
THE FAIR PLAN, YOU KNOW, THE
IBANK HAS GOT TO BE THE
MOTHERSHIP, I GUESS, IN THIS
CASE, TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA STABILIZES ITS
INSURANCE SITUATION. AND I GUESS
THAT'S IT IN A NUTSHELL. THAT'S
IT. I WOULD ALSO ADD, SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THAT I THINK WE OFTEN
READ THE STORIES ABOUT
HOMEOWNERS BEING DROPPED AND
THOSE THAT'S THE VERY COMMON
STORY WE ALL HEAR FROM OUR OWN
CONSTITUENTS. I THINK AT LEAST I
KNOW I HAVE IN EVERY OTHER
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE I'VE
SPOKEN TO WHAT WE DON'T HEAR THE
STORIES OF THOSE WHO DON'T EVEN
GET HOUSED BECAUSE THE HOUSING
CANNOT GET BUILT. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL, THIS BILL IS
REALLY HOW THIS ISSUE CAME, CAME
TO ME IS HOW DO WE PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO, TO MAKE IT
MORE ATTRACTIVE SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN GO IN AND BUILD
THOSE UNITS THAT ARE NOT BEING
BUILT TODAY AND THIS IS A
POTENTIAL TOOL THAT COULD BE
UTILIZED IF THEY FEEL THAT THIS
CAN HELP MINIMIZE THEIR RISK,
THEY MIGHT SAY, I WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS AS A
POTENTIAL SOLUTION IF I GET HIT
WITH THAT MULTI-BILLION DOLLAR
ASSESSMENT, IF THAT WILDFIRE
DOES OCCUR, AT LEAST I HAVE TEN,
20 YEARS TO PAY IT OUT.
THEREFORE, I CONTINUE TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO INSURE PRODUCTS LIKE
BUILDING NEW HOUSING AND I'M
GLAD THE EYE BANK IS BEING
PROACTIVE. AND WITH THAT, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD. YES, ANY MEMBER,
WHEN I READ THIS BILL OVER THE
WEEKEND, I JUST, YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED A LOT IN THE
INSURANCE SPACE AND, YOU KNOW,
IN THE LEGISLATURE OVER SINCE
THE FIRES, 2015 TO 17. AND THIS
IS JUST PROACTIVE. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S SO NECESSARY. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS
AND JUST THE VISION THIS HAD ON
THIS BILL, BECAUSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. HOPEFULLY
WE DON'T NEED TO USE IT. BUT
BOY, TO HAVE IT IN CASE WE NEED
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. WELL
DONE. THANK YOU. OKAY. OTHER
COLLEAGUES WITH COMMENTS ALL
RIGHT THEN AS A MEMBER
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND THE INTEREST IN
TRYING TO HELP A LITTLE BIT WITH
THE INSURANCE CRISIS AND
BUILDING AND THE HOUSING CRISIS.
TWO THINGS AT ONCE. APPRECIATE
AND WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT.
AND DID SENATOR DODD, DID YOU
MAKE A MOTION? OH, I DID,
SENATOR ARCHULETA DID. OKAY.
SENATOR ARCHILLA GAVE YOU A
MOTION. WE'LL CALL THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. ASHBY Ã
ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO.
GIL ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER BECKER I DODD
I DODD I EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLAZER
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO I NEAL
I ROTH SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK I WILK I
. ALL RIGHT, THAT IS 11 TO 0.
BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR
HUSTLING OVER TO HELP US OUT.
APPRECIATE YOU. OKAY,
COLLEAGUES. THAT'S IT FOR OUR
AGENDA. I KNOW A FEW OF YOU
STILL NEED TO VOTE, SO WHAT I'M
GOING TO DO IS RUN THROUGH OUR
OUR ROLE HERE TWICE. AND SO
HOPEFULLY IF THERE'S ANYBODY
LEFT IN THE BUILDING, SENATORS
WHO'D LIKE TO ADD ON OR VOTE,
YOU CAN MAKE IT DOWN BY THE
SECOND TIME THAT WE RUN THROUGH.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL START WITH FILE
ITEM 1AB 2223 BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
CURRIE. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE 6 TO 0. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. BECKER.
DODD DODD. AYE. GLAZER ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK. WHICH ONE?
AGUIAR-CURRY. THIS IS NOT
VOTING. OKAY, SO THAT SITS AT
EIGHT. WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FILE ITEM 2AB 1610 BY JONES
SAWYER. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTES 9 TO 0 WITH CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. DODD
I DODD I. GLASER. ROTH
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. I OKAY. THAT ONE SITS
WITH 11. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM 3AB796 BY
WEBER. THIS IS HER ATHLETIC
TRAINERS BILL DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTES 9 TO 0
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. DODD I DON I GLASER. ROTH.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE
SITS AT 11. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. NEXT UP IS ALSO WEBER AB
2166. THIS IS HER BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY BILL. MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTES 10 TO 0
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. DODD Ã DODD I. GLASER ROTH
. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE SITS
AT 11 AS WELL. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL, NEXT UP WOULD BE OUR,
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS, WHICH
ARE ITEMS FIVE AND SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN VOIGTS.
NINE ZERO DODD I DODD I GLASER.
ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I. ALL RIGHT.
THAT ALSO SITS AT 11. WE WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM SEVEN. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY AB 2115.
HIS CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE BILL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTES
9 TO 0. DODD DODD I GLASER.
LASER I ROTH. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT.
THAT ONE SITS AT 12. BUT WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLL AND SEND IT ON
ITS WAY TO HEALTH COMMITTEE.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM EIGHT. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AB 2832 IS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BILL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTES 8 TO 0
WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING DODD DODD I.
GLASER GLASER I ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I ALL
RIGHT, THAT'S 11 ZERO. WE'LL
CLOSE IT OUT AND SEND IT ON ITS
WAY TO GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM NINE WAS
PULLED BY THE WAY. AND TEN WAS
ALSO PULLED. SO FILE ITEM 11 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN AB 2992
REAL ESTATE LAW MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTES 9 TO 0
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. DODD Ã DODD I. GLASER
BLAZER I. ROTH. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I 12.
WE'RE SITTING AT 12 ON THAT ONE
AND WE WILL SEND IT ON ITS WAY
OUT. THAT IS OUT. NEXT UP FILE
ITEM 12 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ AB 2996 IS HIS FAIR
PLAN. ASSOCIATION HAS AN URGENCY
ON IT. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTES 11 TO 0. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE OR EXCUSE
ME. GLASER GLASER I ROTH. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE'S OUT AS
WELL. 12 TO NOTHING. GO BACK TO
THE TOP OF THE ORDER. THIS CAN
BE OUR LAST. GO THROUGH. ALL
RIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO TWO.
HI, GUYS. AB 2223 BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUILAR CURRY.
CANNABIS INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CURRENT VOTES 8 TO 0. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING BECKER. GLASER. GLASER I
ROTH AND WILK. ALL RIGHT. THAT
IS A NINE ZERO. AND THAT IS OUT
THAT ITEM MOVES ON TO HEALTH. I
BELIEVE. ALL RIGHT. FILE ITEM
TWO BY MR. JONES-SAWYER. THIS IS
HIS CANNABIS BILL AB 1610.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0. CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER I. ROTH ALL RIGHT. 12.
OH, THAT ONE'S OUT. AND ON ITS
WAY TO A PROPS. NEXT UP, AB 796,
FILE ITEM THREE BY WEBER
ATHLETIC TRAINERS, WHICH IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTES
11 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. LASER LASER
EYE. ROTH. GREAT THAT THAT ITEM
HAS 12. IT'S ON ITS WAY. NEXT
UP. FILE ITEM FOR ALSO BY WEBER.
THIS IS HER BARBERING
COSMETOLOGY AB 2166. MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0. CHAIR.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER I. ROTH GREAT. 12 ZERO.
THAT IS ALSO OUT. CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS FIVE AND SIX BY
CHEN AB 1862 AND AB 2107 LASER.
LASER I ROTH CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS 12. BOTH BILLS OUT AND ON
THEIR WAY. FILE ITEM SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY AB 2115
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. THAT'S
OUT. DO YOU ALREADY VOTE ON THIS
ONE, SENATOR GLASER ALL RIGHT, I
THINK THAT'S IT. THEN I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY OTHER ITEMS
OUTSTANDING. THAT'S IT FOR THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU.